it seems like all hell is breaking loose
in texas but also in other parts of the
country there is a winter storm
slamming basically the entirety of the
nation and texas is getting the worst of
it
well i shouldn't say maybe the worst of
it but texas is
under prepared for this and we're seeing
now this severe winter weather hitting
texas a lot of people don't know the
basic things that people in the midwest
know for instance
if you're experiencing experiencing
freezing temperatures and you don't have
heat you need to turn your water on a
little bit
so that it stops the pipes from freezing
and then bursting from the expansion
this is resulting in water mains
bursting it's resulting in
surprisingly this the power outages
people their food spoiling
it was the craziest thing to me i'm
hearing these stories about well the
power goes out refrigeration goes out
and their food spoils i'm like yo put
the food outside
yeah but i guess many of these people
haven't lived in places that are this
cold
texas wasn't prepared for this and
things are getting bad these food
shortages however
are very very serious and so there's a
lot which talk about in that regard but
for some reason
i guess the only thing that the
mainstream media or the corporate press
actually cares about is that
ted cruz was taking a vacation yeah yeah
we all get it bad optics
ted cruz you know he's a federal level
representative he represents the state
of texas to the federal government i
don't know what he would be doing right
now
you know that on a local level but as a
person
he's still a leader and he could do
better ultimately i think the bigger
issue with ted cruz is that he just bent
the knee and gave in to the
outrage mob instead of just calling out
someone like cuomo and saying shut up
i'm taking a vacation
so we'll talk about this but i think the
big issue
we're dealing with right now the bigger
story throughout all of this a lot of
people are talking about energy
we've heard from tucker carlson the
renewables basically caused a large
problem for texas because they may be
renewable but they're
unreliable and texas wasn't prepared to
deal with
this you know essentially energy demand
costs are skyrocketing
the lines are freezing but many on the
left are saying it has nothing to do
with wind it was the gas lines
themselves freezing and
i just got to tell you this ultimately
texas was just not prepared for this
but we've got with us dan turner who is
a how would you describe yourself i
don't want to
what's your title titles are very
important to me so please don't don't
get it wrong
sir i started an organization so
technically i'm the founder of an
organization called power the future
which is an advocacy group for american
energy workers
but i'm an energy expert i'm not gonna
lie yeah and i don't like
i don't think i'm a braggadocious person
um although earlier i said how good i
look for my age so
i guess i'm wrong but uh but but energy
is my my niche how long have you been in
the field
uh five years so we could we get to talk
about uh
what's really going on and if tucker
carlson is correct but we'll save it
we'll get to it
because i also want to debunk some of
these ridiculous memes we've got some
some good
uh irony coming up we also got luke
hanging out well bill gates is also
speaking on this matter and whatever he
says is gospel and we should always
listen to him no matter what but that's
because bill gates is a scientist right
of
not only a sign he's like the the lord
and savior of our
he's like captain save a planet is bill
gates a scientist
he's not a medical scientist he's a
computer scientist a scientist no he's
not he's not he's a businessman
i literally have a shirt that says bill
gates is not a medical scientist it does
really well i just also uh launched
two new shirts that i'm super excited
about and if you want to purchase them
and support me you can
on thebestpoliticalshirts.com
and i'm also really testing the limits
on instagram and if you want to see some
pretty interesting memes go to
i also uh as a side note there's there's
another big story i don't want to talk
about
so i tweeted about the story from time
magazine the shadow campaign
you know whatever and i was being a
little snarky and i said they didn't say
they rigged
the election they fortified it by
changing the laws blah blah
and there's this thing on twitter called
bird watch where regular users are
prompted to fact check the tweet
and i think out of all of them there's
only one that said it was potentially
misleading but they all said
i was correct i was just making a
reference to a time article
so the pointer institute which controls
facebook fact checking
said this is a problem because the fact
checker said yeah tim paul's right time
magazine said this
the fact-checkers are like no so they
wrote a whole article saying it was a
problem that when i was fact check i was
proven correct when they want their
narrative
yes so we also we also got ian however
i'm i'm just aghast away the story you
just told
uh thank you for the throw over tim
what's up everybody welcome to the show
ian crossland.net get a mug say hello
come check out my new website and daniel
great to have you here i'm very excited
to talk about maybe even carbon
recapture technology the future of
reusing the carbon dioxide turning it
into graphene depositing onto metals and
things like that you know interesting
yeah bypass mining that way we also have
sour patch lids pressing on i'm here in
the corner
laughing at these guys and pushing all
the buttons i love my job it's a good
job what can i say
before we get started my friends head
over to timcast.com and become a member
in order to get exclusive podcast
segments
and even full episodes just the other
day we sat down for an hour with james
o'keefe and we really just
went at the mainstream media we really
just tore him to shreds and if you want
to listen to that
that that episode it is a members only
exclusive post
go to timecast.com check it out but the
site really is there because in the
event that we get
purged or nuked or banned or whatever
which is entirely possible
this is where you will find us but don't
forget like share subscribe hit that
notification bell
and let's read the first story texas
is running out of food as weather crisis
disrupts supply chain
texans running low on food are finding
empty grocery store shelves
food pantries are running out of
supplies and the freeze has wiped out
substantial portions of the state's
citrus and vegetable crops
this is from texas tribune they say the
state's week of weather health started
with a 133 car pileup outside of fort
worth a winter storm unlike any texas
has ever seen quickly followed
and seven days later millions are
without power and reliable water
they going to mention here's a quote it
was out of uh
someone uh some are sorting storing the
remaining rations and coolers outside
and trips the grocery store often do
little to replenish pantries saying
quote
it was out of meat eggs and almost all
the milk before i left
crystal porter an austin resident said
about her local target
which she visited monday lines were
wrapped around the store when we arrived
shelves were almost fully cleared for
potatoes meat eggs and some dairy
two days later one of porter's neighbors
went to that same target
and the store was completely out of food
with no sign of additional shipments
arriving or employees restocking shelves
now this is where where emergencies get
scary you know we we've had stories like
this in the past there was one story
about an algebra
in in ohio i think it was and within an
hour of the news breaking
all bottled water was gone now the
difference here with texas is that i
mean this has been going on for what
almost a week now
where the power's gone out millions are
without power people are freezing
and now people don't have food so i
guess i'm curious uh dan because you
know you're the energy guy
if you want to just let's just have a
conversation why why is there no food
what's going on
there's no food because there's no
energy i mean energy does make the world
go around you think of the amount of
energy required
to bring in uh via rail via
truck to restock those shelves right
when when the energy supply disappears
everything else will go with it and
that's why you know i i get very excited
about energy i love this issue we were
talking about it
you know i can become a real geek on it
but it literally is the
the foundation of all of our life we're
all here because we were able to get
here
somehow through energy right we were
able to get in our cars if you took
public transportation which i know
none of us i definitely didn't right but
people who are listening to us right now
people who are watching us right now
from the very first thing you did this
morning think about it at least
for me the very first thing i did was
turn off my my iphone alarm yep
energy the last thing i will do and when
i set my alarm to make sure it's on even
though it's supposed to replace
i always check i will turn off the light
let's uh let's get a little bit more
specific they they mentioned that food
crops are failing well that's simply a
lack of energy
it's not the same kind of energy we're
you know we're talking about talking
about fuels for vehicles
but cold weather is essentially energy
levels going down now their food is
failing
but also i think outside so we'll
definitely talk about the energy issues
i think that's important because
everyone wants to know what's going on
with the electricity yeah
but it was ultimately in a lot of ways
there was
governmental failure here i mean they
didn't prepare properly for how to deal
with winter weather and there are some
jurisdictions bordering texas
where you can actually see you know it's
a in arkansas i think there they they
this image where you can see the roads
are plowed and then in texas it's just
snow all over the streets yeah and and
that's the problem of of government
right it doesn't always work i'm not a
fan of government i'm i'm not an
anarchist but
um i have deep skepticism of government
i dislike government i don't trust
government at all levels
um so that is clearly a a huge
government failure right
and the problem is we turn over so many
of these things our kids education we
turn over
entire swathes of our society because we
assume government's going to be in
charge of it and then when government
fails at their job we say well now
to whom do i turn you know who's not
getting made fun of today all those
preppers yeah right all those people who
were working
i see and you brought it up not me it's
the craziest thing to me because i did a
promo for uh
these food bins sometimes i did a promo
earlier today on my main channel
and it's funny how that's supposed to be
like i see these leftists these
tribalists saying like ha ha tim's
selling food bins and i'm like is that
supposed to make me upset i don't
understand
yeah am i supposed to be like yes people
should not prepare for emergencies
am i am i going to mock somebody for
buying a fire extinguisher people in
texas don't got food right now
but the people who listen to me do yeah
i would even posit that the
a blizzard is a natural disaster like
this is i've never really thought of a
heavy snow as a natural disaster but
it's like a hurricane or absolutely you
know
completely devastating how many people
died 40 some people have already died
yeah last i saw i think the number was
40 41 wow
37 so yeah to say the government's not
prepared is definitely an
understatement here and what you were
talking about here
is of course arkansas and texas there's
a viral photo going around of the same
road and right on the border you see in
arkansas
the roads plowed in texas snow
everywhere and this is in part why a lot
of trucks
are not able to go to the supermarket
you have to understand major cities are
extremely vulnerable because
if the roads shut down your food's not
going to be getting
to you to your community especially in
very congested areas texas did not
invest in snow plows
arkansas did arkansas is used to dealing
with this and this is another reason why
again as i've been saying you need to be
personally responsible for yourself
more than ever i've been selling those
food buckets for years now
and people are like where are you doing
your from i'm like no you know you don't
understand like
how vulnerable everything is in our
society and how in a matter of seconds
everything can be taken away and you're
only responsible for yourself
absolutely and what annoys me about our
discourse is that then when we do have
an election
we will hem and haw as to whether or not
as governor will you allow
this six-year-old girl to identify as a
boy and play gymnastics and you say
can we talk about preparation for for
the next storm right can we talk about
the electric grid can we
these aren't infrastructure yeah they're
not sexy topics they're boring they're
nerdy they put everyone to sleep
but this is what government should be
doing and instead we have we have these
whole sessions about these
little minute and i don't need to
minimize the trauma of that six-year-old
kid but i'm saying
that is not the role of government if
government did its darn job
but it doesn't what texas needed to do
was
i don't know buy salt plows issue
notices to residents saying in the event
of winter weather make sure you turn
your water on
i can't believe all of these videos i've
seen it's crazy where the pipes burst
and i'm like it was a two-second thing
you walk over and you go and you walk
away or even just a little bit
yeah you got to teach little kids that i
mean like i get texas is not used to
winter weather like this
but we had forecast we knew this was
coming this is an absolute failure of
government
100 now on the energy front we're
hearing
you know the win the wind turbine thing
i love this one so i saw a bunch of
posts from conservatives saying that
wind turbines froze and this is the
reason
that the power essentially went out in
in texas
then i saw people on the left saying
wind turbines operate in antarctica
and the real problem was the gas lines
we need a green new deal and this proves
it
i think the craziest thing was uh
patrick moore who is one of the founders
of greenpeace he's no longer with the
organization
he basically said something the effect
of climate catastrophes can't explain
away
this record winter cold and the weirdest
thing is it's really hard to to discuss
when you know we have all of this fake
news coming out
so there's a video going viral of snow
and i guess saudi arabia or something
like that yeah
and they're like oh look at this there's
camels and there's snow on them
and yeah apparently fact checkers are
saying that's actually
normal sometimes it snows especially in
higher altitudes like what are you what
are you saying like deserts get cold
so for some reason though these people
just believe these things not doing any
fact checking but
i want to pull up something that i'm
absolutely thrilled to show all of you
over on reddit's r slash face palm
there's a post that is one of the most
upvoted reddit posts
on the page and it says science
s-i-e-n-s-e
making fun of uh tucker carlson i
suppose and it just tucker carlson quote
he says quote it got cold last night and
the windmills froze
and as a result millions of texans are
freezing several have died
and then underneath it is an image and
it says meanwhile in antarctica
and it has a bunch of penguins standing
around and there are a bunch of wind
turbines
and what appears to be a giant glass
structure of some sort with solar panels
on it
i love this this image is it appears on
r
slash face palm so i don't know
if they're uh self-aware and the face
palm is actually that
they're that the the antarctica thing is
fake
or that we're supposed to make fun
trucker carlson i'm assuming
they're making fun of tucker carlson by
pointing out there's actually winter
vines in antarctica
here's the best part that's a fake image
wow it's
so obviously fake though there's there's
a picture look at these penguins okay
for those that can see this because
there might be for the people listening
i'll explain
there are some penguins they're standing
around doing penguin stuff and then
there's a wind turbine
and standing right next to the wind
turbine is a penguin which stands i
believe what what about a foot and a
half tall
scroll down a bit scroll down yeah cause
you can't see it's behind your head
oh i see i see there you go perfect so
here's here's a little penguin and
they're about they're about a foot and a
half tall i think is it
maybe i'm wrong maybe a foot that's a
good guess yeah yeah about a foot in
half
and standing next to this wind turbine
and if you were to take this penguin
it would the wind turbine's like 15 feet
tall i don't know if you've ever seen a
wind turbine or turbine blades
what are they like 200 feet other 50
something like that no no no no no there
are hundreds of
feet yeah there are hundreds of hundreds
so i don't know how big these penguins
are man but this would mean this
penguin's like 20 feet tall
but then there's a guy in the background
too who and this is this is the best
part
the guy is standing next to to penguins
and these penguins are half as tall as
he is
so these are like two and a half three
foot tall maybe maybe it looks i'm not a
penguin scientist okay maybe it's a gmo
monsanto penguin
yeah maybe that's it you know was it
well i was supposed to brush up on my
penguin yeah
yeah so so hold on let me let me let me
go further
so i i did a simple image search it was
not hard to do the image comes from
some uh italian uh
architecture design event where they had
an exhibit
and uh yes someone was conceptualizing a
plan for green energy in antarctica the
image
is not real you need only google search
it and see
it's a wallpaper that you can buy you
know i did i took the image
loaded it into google image search and
this popped up they're sharing a fake
image
to mock tucker carlson and they're
saying face palm as if tucker is the one
who was wrong
yeah now i still i i did read a lot of
what tucker said
and tucker was i think he should have
been more clear about what was causing
the failure
but the point he was making is that
these these renewable energies are
unreliable
and he's correct as i i i actually made
a whole segment a couple years ago
advocating for the green new deal that
was until aoc put out her critical race
theory laden garbage which had nothing
to do with the environment for the most
part
and then i was like okay that i don't
support but the idea of investing in new
technologies
fusion nuclear wind solar that to me is
a good thing if
we're going to do it that's not what
they're doing now but they're so so that
being said
look when i saw this i know wind solar
you know these these things are
fantastic but they're not reliable how
do you store the energy when there's no
wind and there's no sun
right so i don't know if dan you want to
opine on
on the whole matter of texas and their
energy shutdown yeah and and to do that
i think we need to be careful i know
what article you were reading but they
they we keep hearing that this is a once
in a lifetime once in a century storm
that right there is is needs to be
debunked that's a lie a storm like this
was
just as bad in 2011 it was february 2nd
it was the day after the super bowl
texas does get these types of storms
it's not common and now
maybe screw it up maybe going back to
the early conversation we were having if
you're the governor and you say all
right this storm happens every 10 years
do i invest in x amount of dollars on on
snow plows for something that happens
that i may not even be governor when it
happens
that's another question of government
right
but these storms do happen let's look at
2011 when this storm happened in 2011
the wind capacity for the electric grid
was six percent
right by 2015
because of their mandate rick perry put
in this law by 2015 we
have to be 25 wind and they did
so they went from 6 percent in 2011 to
25
now same storm hit did the same amount
of damage
but now the wind is not 6 percent it's
not a sliver of
the electric mix it is 25 and when that
came offline
that is the delta and when you compare
apples to apples people are like what
happened in california what happened
let's compare texas to texas and if you
compare these two storms
coal performed the same nuclear perform
the same natural gas performed the same
the delta is wind i don't oppose
wind technology i don't oppose solar
panels i i agree with you we should
invest in all of these
but to to deny that they have
shortcomings
is childish and we can't allow children
at this conversation
well they did it was reported that even
natural gas lines have had yes
absolutely they had and not only had
they frozen
really what had happened is that those
texans who have gas for heat
which is a small percentage about 65
percent of texans use electricity
and again if you're building a house why
am i going to invest in gas heat because
odds are i could go the whole winter not
use it once
so i will use the hvac and then the rare
occasion that i need to heat up my home
electricity heat is very expensive i
know yeah that's seriously expensive i
don't i don't
i live off the grid i only have electric
heat and it is very expensive i wish i
didn't have it
but those people who do have gas heat
which is a
enough a percentage well they all jacked
up the thermostat so the natural gas
pipelines that would have gone
to the electrical plants were now
deviated
by magnitudes to people's homes should
texas have been prepared for that
absolutely they should have been
prepared for that so there's lots of
failures of government
failures on multiple levels but to say
that the the thing was not
wind turbine is just a lie
i would say yes we could reduce it even
further and say they should have
winterized the turbines
beforehand i mean so so the thing about
that image i shared
with winter wind turbines in antarctica
is there are wind turbines in it and in
antarctica
i don't know i know i think new zealand
has three
i don't know if there are other nations
that have set up a
wind turbines in antarctica there's two
things to say though
first these turbines are built to be in
antarctica
so it's cold they know it's going to be
cold they're built better they're
designed for
winter more importantly antarctica is a
desert which is another reason why this
image is funny
where they're like look at antarctica
it's a desert there's no there's no
water
to freeze the turbine in texas it was
extremely wet
yeah so i think it's i think it's an
interesting conversation i think
they should have been prepared as a
government but it's also interesting to
see
as soon as wind started to go down the
strain on the system became too much for
the system to bear
when you say natural gas you're talking
about methane which i believe and
correct me if i'm wrong it's ch4 carbon
four hydrogens so when you say that
natural gas is not methane are you
saying it is um
natural when they say natural gas that's
that's just a phrase for methane
as far as i know um it's it's it's a
catch-all
oh there's other gases and absolutely
additional multiple natural yeah
and just look at you've got you've got
propane right that's
that's used in your grill right so um i
don't know what the mix is that texas is
using sorry i was going off the mic i
don't know what the mix is that texas is
it it is primarily methane but it
includes varying amounts of other
uh alkanes such as carbon dioxide
nitrogen hydrogen sulfide
or helium so but i believe it is
primarily methane when they freeze
is that actually the pipes that the the
gas is flowing through
that froze or is it the gas itself that
i mean the gas is is is
gas so in order for to freeze gas it's
got to be super cold i would imagine
you'd have to liquefy it and then
um but so what's happening when when the
gas lines
break it's probably um
i gotta get my mechanical engineer hat
it's probably an issue of the pumping
station
right because all all pipelines need to
have pumping stations to keep them
going water does oil pipelines right
that's the keystone pipeline
wasn't just going to fill up oil in
alberta and have it get to texas 1200
miles
so it was probably those pumping
stations this is where the breakdowns
were
what what's causing the pumping station
are they using coal to
pump to create the heat most pumping
stations are run on fossil fuels yeah
and they probably
literally froze because of the
temperatures and so now you're not able
to pump anything
because of the freezing temperatures
this is the biggest issue
these people don't understand when
they're like why don't we just do more
solar why don't we just do more wind
i love that idea i do i i love the idea
i think fusion is probably better
investment for trying if we
if we want to do green energy just dump
all that money into fusion research
we could also build nuclear power plants
the funny thing though is
we we recently had some solar people
come over here and we're like we want
solar power okay we want to make sure
that in the event this is some kind of
emergency
and so i'm talking to the solar guys and
i said you know and it's and it's a good
idea to like you know get this because
it's going to be cheaper in the long run
right and he was like
i mean after 20 years yeah exactly and i
was like
i was like oh because the cost of
building the solar takes 20 years to
recuperate
and he was like yeah yeah so in the long
run
it's it's great can raise the property
value and it you have power and the
event is an outage that's
really what it's about but uh the guys
were on the level and they said look man
the reason people get solar panels is
because they can afford to
it protects them from emergencies that's
a good idea in terms of efficiency
delivering power in the long run it's
not something everyone's probably going
to want
or be able to do how would you respond
to our lord and savior bill gates who
knows everything and does nothing wrong
when he says
that only 13 of the outages are quote
related to wind turbines this is the
statement that he came out with today
and he also blamed this historic winter
storm
on climate change caused by humans what
would be your response
i i well the joy about the climate
change argument is that everything is
is proof of climate change right so
whether it's hot or cold it's climate
change
um and so that's convenient for it for
him
um if you just look at i mean i do this
research for a living and it's not
impossible to find
the department of energy has every
electric grid
every hour their electric mix you can go
online and look at it
right now and if you just compare which
is what i did for the latest op-ed i
wrote about it
which just came out a couple hours ago
if you compare sunday at eight o'clock
to monday at eight o'clock you can just
see the electric mix and i have photos
of it i don't know if you can throw them
up online somehow you can just compare
the the mix of electricity of what
nuclear is producing
now what was it producing then what
nucleus what what coal is producing
what natural gas is producing and what
wind is producing
wind on sunday was producing 8 000
roughly 8 000
megawatts of electricity that dropped to
600.
right that is a huge difference i mean
like like monster 92 drop or something
you cannot keep and so so uh we we
you know we had a super chat come in
that i think is interesting they
mentioned that ercot
which does what was it the electrical
reliability council of texas reliability
they were saying basically that it's a
trading market
and the cost per unit skyrocketed the
superchat says nine thousand dollars
from where it was normally 25 so people
just weren't coming online it was just
too expensive
and so the system essentially just
crippled itself yeah
and and that's the other problem with
the renewables is that it does they
don't play fairly in the free market
right they
they don't and so when you go off of
renewables because they're not working
and you have to then jack up coal you
have to pump in more natural gas
you have these huge fluctuations the
best example of that is
europe they pay four and five times what
we do for their electric bill
why because they're green i don't oppose
being green right but europe chose to go
green
when they cannot maintain their grid
they have to burn coal like mad and they
have to buy it
fast and they have to buy natural gas
and they have to buy it from vladimir
putin and that's the price of the market
and that's why there's a war going on
absolutely
turkey pipeline to offset the gas from
monopoly oh boy
oh yeah absolutely that's that's another
show that we definitely have to have
right i mean these these are the real
problems when you talk about going
green quote unquote now if we want to go
green and decide that as a country
let's have that honest debate but right
now again as soon as you mention these
things
you are well you don't believe in
climate change well i just want to say
that the american people need to know
their electric bill will multiply by a
factor of four if we go green it will
just how would you uh no i was just
going to say one last point texas
so i was talking about 11 to 2021 right
the 10-year difference of how texas
changed their electric mix
they went to 25 renewable over the
course of a decade
did their electric bill drop by 25 no
it went up probably close to about 30
their electric bill costs
why inflation in part of it may be part
of it inflation but that is a
huge drop for the number one oil and gas
producer in the country
what's why can't the people of texas say
well wait a second what are we getting
for going renewable
and who then someone and this is where i
get a little crazy on this stuff
someone is making a boatload of money
building all these windmills
and i would like to know who's getting
rich off because someone is what
why is doing it i think i do think it's
funny that we call them windmills wind
turbines no but but people do call them
windmills even i did like they used to
milgram
yeah right now we just call them
windmills because they look the same the
little thing
funny you know from inception at the end
the little little wind thing the kid has
oh yeah yeah or also we have the we have
the floppy disk icon for saving things
and like we haven't used those things in
a decade anyway i'm sorry man continue
no no it's a great point i don't even
think some people know what a floppy
disk is
which is pretty funny um doom on seven
discs or whatever
but i just think that the the the people
of texas and now the
american people we're going to go green
we're going to go 100 renewable
by 2035 says president biden a hundred
percent electric
generation renewable by 2035. where do
we store that power where does
where does the cost come from where does
the land come from some of these wind
farms in texas are a hundred thousand
acres
yeah you can't rely on what we need to
do is develop um
geothermal tidal power and gravity power
tidal and gravity are good where do we
do geothermal well you just drill
but where you were particularly right
the reason honestly i'd like to tap into
volcanoes
but that's the iceland it works because
it's a big volcanic
rock i don't know if you can go deep
enough to get to the where it starts to
get hot
boil water with the earth's heat but i
mean it just it makes a lot of sense
it's very common sense but i mean that's
to say that we're just going to be there
without laying out the plan and
explaining all the numbers i think
so where so a lot of people a lot of
people need people need to
understand how we we create electrical
current
my understanding is we have these
turbines they need to keep spinning to
keep the current
running right to keep the current
existing i suppose
so all day and night
what we basically do is we take coal set
it on fire
turns water it creates water pressure
and the water pressure then spins a
turbine
as long as that turbine is spinning
we're generating electrical current that
people can use right
yes just a bit wind turbines are being
turned the turbines are spinning because
wind is hitting them
when the wind stops there's no power
they have to store it somehow
right and so we don't have that
technology
giant batteries this is the craziest
thing i watch i watch this really
amazing educational
mini ish like short film on energy
return on energy invested and they were
talking about why we
love renewable energy why we're so
excited for them
and why they are nowhere near ready for
for
implementation no and the main issue is
when the wind turbine stops spinning for
any reason
the current stops as well and so it's
amazing this idea that we can set up a
bunch of turbines all over the place
but you would you would have to create a
ridiculous amount of them
in order to make sure you're always
generating enough current to sustain
life as as it currently exists
the problem is it takes so much
petroleum energy
to make the wind turbines it makes no
sense no
until we get to the point where we can
we can generate more efficiently
and store that energy these renewables
that we know and love and are excited
about
do not have a high enough energy return
on energy invested
they talk about is really fascinating
why fracking became
profitable and it was because the cost
fossil fuels had become so expensive
because it was getting harder and harder
to actually find oil
that all of a sudden it became
economically feasible to start fracking
a very expensive and dangerous process
which nets fossil fuels but when you
look at the energy
returned from the energy you invest
these green energies just
don't cut it except nuclear energy
the most efficient my understanding is
it's the highest return is that
i could be wrong is that true i'm not
positive but i mean that sounds just
knowing what i know about nuclear it
sounds absolutely right
the way they explain it is something
like for every dollar you put in you'll
get 50
equivalent out or something the easiest
way to explain it the problem is
they won't let us build nuclear energy
either we've been built in new york
because meltdowns
because there were what do we have with
three meltdowns
three everyone keeps talking about three
mile island but no one can tell me
chernobyl what actually happened there
three mile island and fukushima
fukushima was now which was absolutely
chernobyl
melted into the ocean there's corium all
through the ocean fukushima is really
really bad it's pretty bad the problem
is
with so you have these older these older
reactors
they were built we didn't you know we
many i think some have been
decommissioned there are problems don't
get me wrong
the newer technologies i guess there's a
lot of prom a lot of excitement around
thorium salt reactors i don't know a
whole lot about it so you know i'm not
going to get too much into it
but fukushima was a major natural
disaster so we
can now look at that situation and say
what can we do better to make sure this
doesn't happen i think we can pour gold
in the corium because right now
as far as i know about the nuclear core
um it's circulating heat but because it
can't release its heat it
begins to get so hot that it melts down
and then turns into liquid but if we can
somehow
put a superconductor into the corium and
allow it that would allow it to release
its heat
then it wouldn't melt so if you poured
gold into it
which is a superconductor i would
imagine then it would release its heat
it would harden and then you could melt
it thoroughly extract the gold thorium
salt reactors are liquid
so that you don't have to worry about
that yeah thorium apparently doesn't
melt down do you know anything about
thorium no my understanding is that it's
a liquid reactor so there's no concern
over a meltdown
itself but in the milk that's the salt
and then the salt is is boiling
basically which is
don't know enough to get into it okay
all i can really say is
there are a lot of people asking why we
aren't doing building nuclear reactors
because they're completely
carbon neutral i mean well not you got
to use oil to build them right you know
you need that oil energy the other thing
people need to realize too is that
you know we we operate our uh uh
vehicles they're not all electric we
don't have electric uh
you know excavators do we have electric
excavators no and that's the biggest
drawback
again i don't no problem with electric
vehicles drive whatever car you want
um the biggest problem with electric
vehicles is the size of the battery
proportion to the size of the car
the battery lasts only about 10 to 12
years and it's extremely heavy watches
why there are no electric airplanes and
there won't be for anytime soon
well the weight of the battery is insane
there there
are and they can't carry people well
there's one a guy flew around the world
in the first solar-powered airplane yeah
five years ago yeah and it took them
like
12 days and they did create a solar
power plane
that or a drone that can fly
indefinitely well until the parts break
yeah because it's it's a massive ultra
lightweight
lighter huge so make sure people you
have your pedal
uh you ever see those gyro gyro what are
called gyrocopters
you paddle with your arms and your legs
yes backup power and it still has an
engine on it though
but there was a university where they
actually created a fully human powered
flying machine
it was as big as this this airplane
hangar and the guy's pedaling like crazy
and he gets a few feet off the ground
and then he starts coming back down
because you know
he gets he gets super tired but uh i
want to ask a question
what would you call it if someone called
for
if there was let's say there's a high
profile public figure who came out and
said
i will not wait i demand that an
action be taken which will result in the
death of hundreds of millions of people
what would
what do you call it when someone when
someone tries to enact a plan that would
kill hundreds of millions of people
excessive what are like government
government
democrats democrat wait what is
demonstrated is uh death by government
it's the number one leading cause it's
the number one leading cause of death in
human history
so i'm just trying to what's the word
for a person genocide i think is the
word is that it
are you sure you're saying you're saying
greta tuneburg called for genocide
you're talking about killing
hundreds of millions of people yeah yeah
yeah by taking it yeah that would be
generous
so you're saying that greta toonberg
called for genocide indirectly because i
didn't say that word you did
you see yeah i tricked you but i
wouldn't even say she called it reddit
soonberg said we will not wait till
2030.
or should we do not want to wait till
2030 or 2022 we want
now a moratorium on facebook people that
are screaming about
what their goal is i need to scream
about the plan i need to explain this
otherwise
the genocide thing greta tunberg said we
want a moratorium on oil
now we want it done if we stop using oil
our freight the freight lines our trains
the food delivery systems
transporting of emergency medicines all
of this just stops
and immediately overnight you're gonna
see riots in the street
from starving people you remember what
happened in in paris
in france when emmanuel macron was like
we're going to put a tax on
patrol you know because we're going
green or whatever and then would they
get like a year and a half of people
rioting
because all of a sudden their gas bill
was too high because they were trying to
tax them to go green
people want to live you know i was
actually surprised to find out that
that people are fond of living yeah
surprising huh so so when the government
comes in and says
we're not just sacrificing your your
quality of life
we're restricting your ability to feed
your family while we fly on private jets
yeah
exactly yeah you bring up a very
important point because when you see
the government's response to the climate
crisis it usually means
hurting the average person the middle
class person
the low-class working person they're the
ones that are going to be paying for it
as they literally flying around in their
private jets and don't give a
darn and sometimes even profit off of
this new you know idea or innovation
that's a carbon tax
a tax on your breath a tax on your co2
and i'm like how more ridiculous could
they get i could just see them sitting
around in the table being like we're
just going to tax them for breathing
this time whoa whoa you're forgetting
the uk
yeah they're going to tax you and you're
going to need a license for it exactly
and and it's just
like if if you think government
licensing is going to solve
anything i demand you spend one week at
the dmv
mandatory if you're ever going to
advocate for such a policy
now i i will i will you you want to i
want to finish this because you know
just recently i made my rv
to be uh i made my rv off the grid i
installed a lot of solar panels and i
learned
it doesn't matter how many solar panels
you have if you don't have batteries
in them that i could that could actually
save the power and
and when you're talking about the
battery technology it's not there
and i was like wait how many how many
pounds do these things weigh 200 pounds
and i was like you have to factor in
weight especially if you're in an rv
and the battery technology you know you
would think you would you would spend
some innovation and some
money and some investment and some
technology looking into
making that better but it's not there
yet and educate luke on new better
technology
well i was just reading about uh
graphing batteries we're talking about
superconductors
um i was actually just reading about uh
condensing graphene or
carbon dioxide into graphene and what
you do
is let me i'll read this this is from
digi design news.com
and the title is researchers develop
graphene from carbon dioxide
um it says that the project endeavors to
synthesize graphene
uh specifically mimicking photosynthesis
by turning carbon dioxide and oxygen
metal-based enzyme ribulose
uh biphosphate carboxylase oxygenase
and um a little into carbon dioxide a
little bit too in the wheat
this is a really just confused this is a
really technical article but ultimately
we're going to have to advance our
battery power
we should we have to i want to contain
lightning energy we should be using
lightning as our
power supply the problem is we don't
know the charge of lightning we've got
to pound these batteries with it and
just store it
so the reason i i shot it as graphene is
this this is the we are we are moving
towards really great advancements in
solid state better technologies
graphene based battery technologies
here's the crazy thing we talked about
before i recently bought
i think i bought like five uh graphene
composite batteries they use lithium ion
technology but they're there's like a
lattice of graphene through it
which allows it to charge it like the
whole thing it's two and a half cell
phone charges worth of power
charge up in about 10 or 15 minutes so
normally you plug your phone and it
takes 20 30 minutes
now it's half the time cutting edge this
is like when we have like 32 kilobyte
computer
ram stuff i mean in 10 years it's going
to be we're going to be able to charge
in like two seconds and we're going to
have days of power
the big problem is batteries
and they're particularly brutal i mean
when if you get a punctured battery and
it blows up on a phone
yeah that's why they they tell you on
planes you can't bring lithium-bat
lithium-ion batteries on the planes
and they're brutal for the environment
and lithium-ion batteries are primarily
made of bauxite and bauxite has mined
90 of it in the congo by slave children
and let's be honest about that
yeah right so we're all going to have
electric vehicles joe biden has said
they're all going to have electric
vehicles
well how many more slave children are do
we need to employ or well that
you employ slave children i don't know
what the proper term is that right
these are just the real conversations we
have to have about going green
and also china having these rare earth
minerals that they have a monopoly on
defense but they're also just yesterday
threatened the united states about
setting up an emporium where they won't
be sending it to the united states but
you know they're not really rare
well they're called they're called rare
earths but but it's just that nobody is
mining them properly
we have them all in america right but oh
but china can do it so we don't want to
do the labor absolutely so if you wanted
to be really green you would allow us to
buy them you can mine them here it would
be better for the environment we would
have great standards
can we just get some of these like
environmental leftists to admit we live
in a neo-feudalist system
where people in europe and the united
states get to live off of the slave
labor of the serfs in the congo mining
the bauxite and
china in this in the rare earths one of
my most disliked people in
in alive right now is a guy named tom
steyer who's a billionaire
um a big environmental cause funder
um he vehemently opposes coal in america
goes out of his way to try to shut down
coal mines in america does not want any
more coal
he made billions of dollars off of
investments in coal and indonesia and
china
so he'll be damned if a guy in west
virginia is going to going to mine for
coal
but a nine-year-old girl in western
china totally cool but don't you get it
he's kicking the ladder down after he
made it to the top of the mountain
absolutely he's like you can't come up
here i'm rich
you're right it it really is a feudal
system to a certain extent look at
john kerry on his private jet leonardo
dicaprio no no no no no no no
john kerry flew in a private jet to pick
up an environmentalism award
and that's like a fire truck on fire i'm
sorry i love that and trust me if i had
married a rich heiress i
too would not sit in the middle seat
between like the nursing mom
and the girthy millennial like i would
much rather
be on a private jet flying the ice yeah
i wouldn't be like ted cruz trying to
get myself bumped up to first class
which he unsuccessfully did no no no no
i heard he did get it
i heard he did it that's that's the
story that i heard right there but also
bill gates flew to the paris accords in
his private jet yeah
so not many people know that the last
big googled pre-covered when google had
their big climate uh um
climate change summit in sicily and
something like 147 private jets
flew to it you know prince harry took
one and everyone 147 private jets you
know
flew to the to the climate change summit
you don't i guess you don't jet pool
like a carpool yeah like hey
tim i'll pick you up we'll fly the jets
together some do some do you know
it's fun i'll give you a ride any time i
private you know what the meeting was
really about
i really doubt they all sat down and
looked at each other and said man this
global warming's a bad thing we got
we got to figure out how to save the
planet what they really did was they
said
we can't have all these poor people
flying on planes how do we make sure
that we can stay on our private planes i
don't want to lose my private plane
yeah that's what it is you get everyone
else to sacrifice so you don't have to
yes
and and and that's where we are when it
comes to a lot of these green decisions
right
i just want to know who are the people
that are going to die we know who the
people that are going to lose their job
we talk about it well they'll get a
green job in the future okay
if i'm a keystone pipeline worker i've
been now three weeks without a paycheck
so when's my green job coming
up the future is green i wanted to
expand a little on this battery
conversation there's another article by
wired
are radioactive diamond batteries a cure
for nuclear waste this is a good one you
might want to pull up looks simple well
we have uh there was a big breakthrough
recently on
solid state battery technology yeah
which apparently would revolutionize
everything it's like higher energy
density so
this stuff takes the spent nuclear rods
from nuclear power plants which normally
we have to store in like boxes that are
just in yuck
for a thousand years now you encase them
in glass
and you use it as a heat source for
electricity and they last a thousand
years
yes it came out august of 2020 i mean
this is literally here we just need a
president or a
system that understands and wants to
push it it's a it's political right
i think they're ignorant you you you no
one look
in the world of politics these people
are looking at what's going to get them
elected
nuclear is scary we've already seen the
giant lizard breathing radioactive fire
and
blowing up buildings and now people are
scared that they're going to you know
grow a third eye or whatever and they
think nuclear energy is the apocalypse
nope my understanding is that nobody
died in three mile island no
no one even got a cold chernobyl however
was
failures of the communist party
absolutely and it was a
look what happened with chernobyl was a
complicated
but political it was war it was cold war
and the soviets were rushing full speed
they had a system where people would
like when you live
under under under authoritarianism you
just say whatever you need to say to
survive
and so when they were having more and
more problems and people are like yeah
everything's fine everything's fine
and that's what they kept doing and then
we got it you know it got really bad the
whole thing went up and there's a lot of
problems there
don't get me wrong that's scary that's a
that's a major crisis but hold on
what's worse all of the nuclear energy
disasters we've seen so far
or all of the oil spills deep water
horizon
the oil sucks and the damage that it's
caused the dead zones it creates in the
oceans
look i think fossil fuels are important
and and i think the challenge right now
is that we have
you know what we're at 7.8 billion
people we're trying to make sure they
don't die
because we want them to live but while
recognizing it takes a lot of energy
to make sure these people are getting
food they're getting heat some people
don't have food or heat
yeah you know and and we actually try to
subsidize that to help them because we
don't want people to die
but the problem now is you've got people
saying curtail the use of our most
efficient form of energy so far okay
well then all these people are gonna die
yeah and and that is the adult
conversation we need to have
um there is no perfect fuel source i
wish there was there's no perfect energy
source i wish there were but
but i'm not plato right it is not me
versus this ideal
we have to live in the in the reality
and the reality is
everything has its drawbacks but for the
price point
for the efficiency and for the quality
of life we demand and this is
my biggest argument when it comes to the
fossil fuel industry and getting rid of
it is
that is where they want to sacrifice
cost does it matter doesn't matter if we
pay what germany pays
efficiency doesn't matter it doesn't
matter if we can't store the electricity
that's why you hear authoritarians say
well
kamala harris was asked should we talk
about dietary regulations and she said
you know i think we should have a
conversation about that let's talk about
those cheeseburgers the government's
going to regulate our food
yeah built they said no more meat no
bill gates also bought
the most amount of farmland than anyone
else in the united states specifically
because he wants everyone to eat
fake meat live in the pot and eat the
bugs absolutely
i will not eat the bugs there are a
class of people that think that they
have the authority over us to to
determine the quality of life we wanted
i think that that is how you really get
a revolution that is how you get
bloodshed
i i would like to point out though i
actually think that the idea of having a
pod
is pretty cool just as we're talking
about in the middle of the woods
got my own little place got my own
little little little home that's what
i'm doing
yeah yeah and another thing too is the
other thing too is i i see this meme
it's like i will not live in the potter
when i eat the bugs and i'm kind of like
why is it bad to eat bugs like i i look
there's
where's that like 85 percent of the
planet eats bugs you don't have to eat
bugs if you don't want to that's
i i think it's fair if you say i don't
want any bugs i'll buy that's cool i
don't eat bugs
but i'm also kind of like food food but
like lobsters or bugs
big big insects another thing
we have to kind of comprehend here is
that bill gates
invests his money into specifically
creating fake meat
he then goes on 60 minutes and anderson
cooper is like wow
this is such a great idea i love this
idea
as he's promoting fake meat he has no
fat in it
that's the problem there's a lot of
problems surrounding this especially
genetically modified food which bill
gates has extensive ties to especially
to corporations like monsanto
that have a horrendous human rights
record that have a horrendous record of
actively knowingly hurting people and
still doing it for profit
i just think the idea that the second or
third richest person in the world
whatever he is today he's second or
third
and a vanderbilt heir sat down together
and they talked about the sacrifices we
have to make
a millionaire and a billionaire deciding
what we should what sacrifices
we're going to and a republic is a
well-armed populist contesting that vote
holy cow
like that's some that's some scary stuff
right there yeah i don't want to be part
of that world i'm
like the little mermaid i don't want to
be part of your world
i want to we we talked about the the
great reset you're familiar with i'm
sure
yeah and scary a lot of people are
wondering if they're doing it on purpose
and i'm like listen we don't need to ask
what they're doing on purpose what
they're doing is in effect creating
the great race that they've talked about
so you want to get conspiratorial you
can find
we don't have to be we just say i don't
i don't care what their intention is
the result is this great reset they're
locking us down they say it's for the
pandemic sure
this is what's happening now that being
said
part of me you know because we had we
had jack murphy on the show
and i mentioned they want people to live
kind of you know more in the country and
more
back to nature like chopping rolling up
their sleeves and chopping their own
lumber and
and jack was like what's wrong with that
so there's a part of this where it's
like listen
i believe in freedom if you want to eat
your burger with with
ketchup schlopp all over it or whatever
you like on your burger mayo pickles
lettuce you know cheese or whatever you
go ahead and do it i however think
there's a lot to be gained
from regular people who are addicted to
this system
getting out learning how to work going
to the woods
actually learning how to raise chickens
raise raise uh
meat pig cow or whatever and just being
responsible for themselves for once in
their lives
too many americans are gluttonous
living in big cities demanding the
government do the work or or take the
labor from other people to pay for them
yeah they're not you're absolutely right
um uh
i am born and raised in new york city i
lived in dc for a very very long time
i have a year now my my fiance and i uh
got a little farm
and where where's chickens uh chicken
sheep turkeys peacocks
aren't chickens awesome i love them yeah
they're they're fun what do the peacocks
do
uh they're full they make noise they
make a lot of noise
they are ultimately for profit can you
sell them
we will we bought them as eggs and we
will sell them you know like really rich
people we're the poorest people in town
really rich people will want them for
their lawn to walk around and strut like
flannery o'connor amazing so we'll sign
to you at
three years of age you do have pea hens
as well we have
uh the females yes and they lay eggs you
eat the eggs
um they're not old enough yet to lay
eggs uh well
i mean hopefully the eggs will be
fertilized and we'll have more of them
do you have roosters for your chickens i
have too many roosters and aren't they
hilarious
they are and they're there it can be
very mean yeah i know but it's really
funny but like
this is running like yelling at you and
you've got scrapes all over me
but but the point i was gonna make is i
was that dc a
feat you know like like going to brunch
and getting a reservation was the big
thing and you didn't do manual labor and
i have for the last year
and this goes back to benjamin franklin
and thomas jefferson who argued how it
was man better but it goes back to lock
and hops it goes back to plato aristotle
where is mankind better situated and i
have been thinking a lot about how i do
feel like a better human being because i
have to
make fence posts and i have to mend
things and i get dirty and i have to
play with chicken feces and
it's gross and it's work and it's labor
and you
and it's freezing cold and you have a
hangover and and you smoke too much the
night before and your lungs are killing
you but the animals need to eat and
they're in the barn and they are
hungry and and it does make you a better
person i am a better person in the
country
i really are a great feeling from eating
your own
homegrown eggs yes it's very it's very
so amazing
so when i lived in miami we had chickens
and i'd go out in the morning
i'd grab a couple of the eggs bring them
back in and i would i would bake with
that yeah it was um it was awesome i was
like this is so cool like this
these things are at my yard like eating
bugs and they poop these things out and
i put in my pancakes it's great now i
have a leg up though for anyone who's
watching the show who's like
uh oh so i can start a farm my fiance is
a legit
uh aussie outback cowboy who grew up on
25 000 acres
and he did this his whole life so i had
some i had
cheating i right like he thinks this is
a joke like you know we have so easy
a couple sheep and chickens like this
isn't i had you know five thousand head
of cattle
in my on my wow on my ranch um so
so i have a leg up but still it's a
great it makes you a better
person it's fun and it's exciting and
it's different and you learn so much and
you learn so much
about life i lived on a pig farm this
summer uh
very gratifying it smelled a little bit
but but i learned
a lot of really interesting things about
nature and how the world works that you
would never understand in a big city
and you know what we have is a couple of
starting interrupts we have a we have
all heritage breeds which you
who talked a couple of times about gmos
right there are these breeds that that
are dying and we're trying to we're
doing our little part to save them
because
we have cross bred them so many times
for meat for
for large breasted chicken for fattier
pigs so we have all heritage breeds and
they're not as pretty they're maybe not
as tasty they're not as
but they're but they're awful and
they're real and they're
fun looking they're funny-looking
they're kind of ugly yeah
people need to understand the genetic
splicing and and the genetic
kind of larger kind of organizations
that that are putting together these
wild
experiments are absolutely mind-boggling
and
scary to say the least my friend
accidentally became a pig farmer
um because the government said kill all
the pigs right when kovet hid
they were like well you know rather be
safe than sorry kill all of them he went
to a local farm picked him up
illegally and then brought him to his
farm and
then we learned like oh yeah these are
you know specifically bred
pigs just to get fat they're not to run
around they're not to live they're
they're just
going to be sitting here and eating and
that's it here's here's the question i
have for your you know your average
rural living conservative wouldn't you
like for just once in their lives these
urban liberals
to understand why you need a weapon why
you need a gun when you're out in the
middle of nowhere and you've got some
animals and you're worried about feral
hogs
or you're worried about coyotes and you
got to protect those you care about not
just your animals but your family
wouldn't you want them to experience for
once in their life why they have to chop
lumber why they have to go out and make
sure they get enough wood for the for
the stove
because you're not going to have
necessarily the propane delivery in time
if the if the roads are slicked up
wouldn't you just want them to
experience hard work the problem is
well it's i think it sounds good
teaching people responsibility
getting them out to go you know actually
learn how to survive and be responsible
for themselves
the people who are orchestrating these
big changes the people who are calling
for these changes
don't want people to actually be freed
independent yeah they're advocating for
taking away the weapons of these
individuals
and i know a lot of people say tim the
second amendment isn't about hunting and
stuff like i i i know i know it's
literally about securing a free state
but one of the biggest reasons anybody
would need to know how and be trained
with a weapon
is you've got to protect your home you
live in the middle of nowhere where you
don't got cops
but more importantly you hear the
coyotes out in the back and what happens
when they come for your chickens
you pepper them up with some birdchat or
something scare them away or whatever it
is you do or even feral hogs when they
come they come in large droves they come
in large numbers and a high capacity
magazine is something
you're going to need having a 10 round
magazine sometimes won't suffice and
will you'll have in danger you'll have
to have a bunch of magazines well even
then reloading and loading
takes a while and during stressful
situations people mess that up
so so again it's nonsensical and it's
going to hurt people on so many
different levels and and you bring up
very important points i try to shame the
coyotes into not doing it
i give them bad reviews i tweet negative
things you try to cancel them
i do yeah it's like shame on you and i
take pictures and i tell them you know
we're going to kick them out but they're
going to tell their boss on them
but but this this all goes back to i
mean where it's just a great
conversation but i started my
organization exactly for what you were
talking about that these
these urban elites these people who were
three generations removed from
oh maybe my grandfather was a coal miner
or my great grandfather but now i am a
true
urbanite and i'm an urbanite i grew up
in new york city for et cetera et cetera
but they make decisions about the
livelihood of people in towns
michael bloomberg is going out of his
way to close coal mines in america
he he is destroying small towns in
kentucky west virginia
new mexico wyoming he wouldn't land one
of his
g6s in west virginia because there's no
four seasons there
he wouldn't spend spend a second in
artesia new mexico
but he will destroy their livelihood he
will take away the only source of income
they have
and that is shameful bloomberg is the
guy who said to tax the poor
because they're too stupid to spend
their own money properly and in that
same speech which was with christine
lagarde at some
uh uh you know you know um bilderberg
conference
he said you know the coal miners will
find other things for them to do
the code and i thought we will find
other things for them to do first of all
who the heck is we
and what are these other things do they
get a choice it's like john kerry
talking about well they have a better
choice now they'll become
solar panel technicians do i get say in
this new job
right what am i what did you did you see
what uh what cast am i born into who was
it was it was it peter ducey or steve
i don't know which one's the kid which
one's the dad the fox news journalist he
asked jen sackey
the biden administration press secretary
a lot of uh people just lost
jobs because joe biden ended the
keystone pipeline construction it was
like 10 000
good union jobs gone when can they
expect to get these green jobs that
biden has promised
and her response was can you prove to me
they can't get jobs and he was like what
yeah you no no but biden said there will
be new green jobs i'm asking when like
i don't know what you're talking or like
it was entirely adversarial
the idea that the problem with this
though is you think somebody who knows
how to build an oil pipeline
that line of work can just magically
teleport to a solar plant
a solar power a solar panel factory and
no no what they're doing we've already
said though that solar panels isn't the
answer we need new battery tech right
and when you ask these politicians how
what are you going to do they're like
i will find the best minds that will
figure
out how to do it but another thing we
really need to discuss that that's not
really talked about a lot especially in
american mainstream media
is the waste is the pollution is the
utter
crap that's being spewed by third world
countries countries like china that
pollute on massive levels and there's
there's no regulations there's no
michael bloomberg flying over there
telling them what to do no 95 of the
plastics in the ocean
come from southeast asia 70 of it comes
specifically from china
hold on hold on greta toonberg says
we're the ones who got to change and she
doesn't go to china what do we do we ban
straws
just think about the logic of this right
there is so much plastic in the pacific
ocean
that washington dc has a straw and you
say well
what the heck does one have to do with
the other well it feels good and why we
applaud this
yeah i was in i was in texas i was doing
out i think i think was when i went on
the glen back program
and i was at a uh some restaurant in the
airport
i ordered an arnold palmer uh i enjoyed
all arnold palmer you guys like on
iced tea lovely drink well the waitress
came up to me and she was uh
it was it was kind of funny because she
handed me a paper straw
and she apologized and i laughed she no
no no she legit she like
brought to me and she pulled the paper
straight goes i'm sorry yeah and i
looked at i started laughing and i was
like i
it's fine and she goes why did they ban
straws
and then she brought up your point i'm
like here's a waitress who knows that we
are not and then i asked her about it i
was like that's a really good point and
most people don't know that
and started talking to me about a bunch
of political stuff and i'm like
how is this waitress knows and
understands the problem better than
these politicians do i know
that's the problem a regular person
looks into it researches and says
well what is banning straws going to do
do you ever see the video of the straw
up the turtle's nose
and these people find this turtle
swimming in the water and they pull it
out and it's stuck
so they take pliers and they go in and
they start to try and pull it out of the
turtle and it starts bleeding and the
turtle's screaming in pain
it's a video on youtube i'm sure and um
they they just work his face and
basically
commit surgery on this destroyer so
plastic in the ocean is devastating
why is greta tunberg coming and speaking
to europeans and americans saying
how dare you we must stop it's like okay
can we fly to china so you can have a
conversation with what they're doing
like i'm not trying to
i mean literally china right now as we
are speaking is building
more coal plants than all of europe
currently has actually and they promised
to stop
there they lied absolutely and they're
never going to stop
why are they building coal plants
because it works you can say coal is bad
you can say coal is good
i am going to say coal works and china
is serious
they have a world to conquer they're not
going to face what texas is facing you
think china's gonna allow
one of this uyghur concentration camps
making nike sneakers
to ever go dark they are serious and so
they are building
serious infrastructure these are
the chinese communist party will burn
the entire plant to the ground before
they they see
power absolutely well also if you
remember they're the ones taking a lot
of the plastic from the west
there was a big controversy between them
and canada recently as well
and a lot of people found out when they
were taking the plastic to allegedly
recycle it and were being paid to
recycle it what they were doing
they were throwing it in the water and
that's why we have this huge
island made of plastic that specifically
came from china and what are they doing
now they're not only polluting and
throwing a lot of waste on the water
they're also expanding their wetter
sorry part of me here their weather
modification program
which of course they actively used they
used during they used it
used it during their olympics but
they're now making sure that they're
going to be able to manipulate the
environment to their own personal
benefit
which is going to hurt a lot of
countries surrounding them as well
uh we saw a lot of tragic stories coming
out of china specifically with them
trying to stop
rain during the olympics causing massive
flooding in other areas
they're now expanding this to huge
levels that we don't even
know about don't even comprehend and the
devastating effects from this will be
far bigger than even some pollution
according to some experts i think
there's just cultural differences though
between us you're right you're right
you're right cultural norms cultural you
know i
i have so much respect for joe biden he
didn't want to be a xenophobe like trump
was
you know how dare trump call out china
for not warning
for lying to the world about the
coronavirus and igniting this massive
pandemic
it wasn't bigoted of him because the
only reason he did it was because
it's china yeah that's the only reason
and china has so many vulnerabilities
that if we were
serious about freedom and and the
livelihood of our fellow mankind
we could [ __ ] china they need to
import 12 million barrels
a day of oil whoa you don't want to be
racist there buddy
you can't talk about china like that joe
biden says it's just cultural
differences you know we got to let them
do their thing
right we we could just stop sending all
of our jobs there right
we could stop buying nike sneakers we
could stop stop watching disney right
like
we could easily end the china wrath but
we just choose not to because it's
convenient it's cheap
this is why this is why i was saying
part of me just wants like
a legitimate call for people to get
back to nature to some degree go out and
tend to the chickens man
chickens are hilarious i don't
understand how a person could look at a
chicken and not laugh yeah
it's it's like watching them do their
thing is like it's just hilarious and
watch chickens do their thing
and maybe this pandemic has showed us
that you really can live
anywhere right if we can work remotely
then then get the and i'm from queens so
anyone who's from queens you know
get get the heck out of queens go go
just a couple you know
it's 60 70 miles and your life will
change dramatically the air is better oh
the people are nicer i had a hard time
leaving la
like i felt like i was failing like i
failed in my life
because i was leaving the mecca but it's
just the day of decentralization is upon
us yeah
so we have out here a city
a city of cardinals i've never seen
so many cardinals when so it's it's
snowed recently
everything is white i look in the tree
and there's red spots all over the tree
and i was like
damn yeah living in the city you see one
and you go hey look a cardinal
oh man exactly out here it's like all
the cardinals won't go away
yeah yeah and you see bluebirds and you
see different flowers and you hear
different
sounds and if if people got away from
these cities
rolled up their sleeves did a little bit
of hard work their lives would improve
and it would cut off the supply line to
these corrupt companies
like disney praising the paramilitaries
in xinjiang it would cut off nba and
these other
companies it's like it's i'm reminded of
that simpsons episode just don't look
you know the trousers of horror when the
advertisements come to life just don't
look
i i got to tell you man if i had a
choice between watching the super bowl
and watching a chicken
walk around i picked the chicken i'm not
kidding it's funny
it's just like it's hilarious you look
so dumb i caught myself staring out the
window this morning
at the snow falling for like 10 minutes
i was just standing there beautiful
looking outside and it was like
betsy was sitting next to me the cat and
it was like she was watching outside too
and i
realized it's like tv like we're
watching it's like better tv
in a lot of ways it is tv for cats
people are a lot happier and and
healthier living out in the wild living
out in nature there's no crazy
crackheads there's no pollution there's
no stress
and there's no guy beating you over the
head with a baseball bat which just
there's a viral video going around in
new york city right now
there's no cuomo putting sick people
into your into your nursing homes and
killing your parents
threatening assembly members that
they're going to be destroyed if they
don't say nice things about
that particular response yeah i mean i
lived in the city
too growing up and uh i hate it i'm
so happy i'm not there anymore and i'm
telling you like you feel stuck
in there i mean i felt stuck i was like
i can't leave new york city if you can't
make it in new york city you can't make
it anywhere yeah i i love the city i
love the nightlife i love being able to
go out and then
kobe had happened and then i'm like this
is an absolute police state tyrannical
hell hole
that's the epitome of the worst elements
of communism mixed in with big brother
literally
stomping you in the face with its boot
every single chance and opportunity that
they get
there's new york city inspection
officers literally running around
with binoculars trying to look through
your windows to make sure that you're
not
socially distancing enough there's
people rummaging through your trash even
before covid making sure you recycled
correctly meanwhile the whole recycling
uh
whole agenda is a scam anyway how about
you know jack murphy telling us that he
was like lifting weights in his front
yard with his kids and the neighbors
called the cops on him three times the
carriage
the camera why would any you know what
man i don't like
the authoritarians telling people to
live in the pod
in a city that smells like sour milk
yeah there's a way out
okay if you don't want to live in the
pond you don't eat the bugs you move out
to the middle of nowhere
life is probably in some ways harder but
life is more fulfilling
i saw a meme the other day where it was
i think we mentioned on the show it's
it's bob from the incredibles he's a
superhero right but now later in his
life he's an insurance adjuster or
something and it's like
the meme was me at work contemplating my
worth my pointless existence or whatever
my purposeless existence and i'm like
bro your life is only purposeless
because you are living in a concrete
block stacked stacked on top of other
concrete blocks
in a city that smells like sour milk and
if you go out
and get away from this not only here's
the thing here's the pitch to the
environmentalists
you want to save the planet you want
less carbon emissions
advocate for people to go out to some
hard work on their own stop relying on
fossil fuels for your energy and use a
little human power
yeah chop that wood yourself or relocate
your headquarters rather than
on you know the the lower east side of
manhattan on where like the sierra club
is
go out into the country open a
headquarters in in rural ohio if you
really care about the earth
but look at where these groups are
located they're located in new york
they're located in dc san francisco
and and the bigger problem i have with a
lot of the elites of this country
is that they push this lifestyle through
their policies through their
through their political giving but when
when
the crap hit the fan what did they do
they jumped on their jet and flew to the
hamptons they flew to the bahamas they
flew to cancun that's the problem with
the ted cruz thing is not that he left
it's that people don't like that he had
a choice yeah i
am stuck here but i have the choice to
leave and if we're all in this together
well you can't say that remember that
meme that said uh celebrities spell out
hope on their yachts
it's true we're not all in this together
if you
are pushing these policies but you have
a a 40 million dollar beach house and
that has true and then you also live by
a different set of rules that don't
apply to anyone else
but but you yeah they get to scoot
around they get to go to restaurants
they get to go get their haircuts
meanwhile you can't go outside you can't
even meet your family
you can if you have enough money if
you're in the club not in the cities
we can walk outside right now no masks
on and no one cares
in fact you can walk outside here shoot
a gun nobody cares yeah you live in the
middle of nowhere you get more space and
i i've talked to my friends about this
when i said i was leaving new york city
they're like why would you leave new
york and i said listen
the closer you are jammed to other
people your personal
bubble of your like your freedom gets
compressed compressed
you can't even play music in your new
york apartment because you've got four
neighbors complaining with a loud noise
you move out to the suburbs now you can
play music in your house and your
neighbors mostly don't care but
six in the morning you want to go
outside and maybe target shoot or
something
you can't do that in the suburbs of the
country you can run to the country
and you can go outside with a 50 bmg
semi-auto and just
unload as long as you got appropriate
backstop and you know you're
you know properly acting and i think
it's funny when these i see all these
posts like we had this thing happen with
laura bobert she had she was doing a
zoom call
lauren sorry lauren barber she was she
had the guns behind her and all these
like leftists are like what is she doing
with guns i'm like why do you care she
lives in the middle of nowhere
that's colorado i know where that is why
would i want to live in a city
where i have these karen's screaming at
me about
me doing something like you know just
like just something innocuous working
out in your backyard working out in your
front yard like i'm gonna call the
police
okay look man i'm gonna go to the middle
of nowhere where i can
go outside in in mid-morning buck naked
scream and just fire some guns it's like
a different world whatever you want the
internet man it is a different world
when i was a kid when i was seven
eight nine i was taught that you needed
to be in a big city to have access to
technology and people yeah and in the in
the country you're isolated and it is
completely different now you go to the
country high-speed internet
you start a an empire this is one of the
reasons why new york city is going to
collapse a lot of people
aren't coming back because they're
realizing they don't need to come back
everything that they used to do at the
office you know at their workspace they
could do online
businesses are realizing this they're
not even asking people to come back
and that's why a major swap of of real
estate in new york city is going to be
redesigned to be apartment buildings
rather than office buildings who's going
to live there when there's no jobs yeah
well it's funny because de blasio's like
we're going to buy up these old
buildings how they've been like you shut
you destroyed the city yeah
and then he buys it up it's like robocop
you know the evil
the evil gut line yeah watch the
original robocop it's extremely
eye-opening
and you're right who's gonna want to
live there yeah i know i am always a
proud new yorker i love new york i mean
i always consider new york home
you get this little swagger when and i
my accent comes back when i go back to
queens
uh when i order pizza you know uh
but there is a there is a deep
anger in that city and pre-covered yeah
right people people
are are and you can't have unsatisfied
not making enough money yeah they're
paying
4 500 a month in rent for a room that's
smaller than i've heard it's the brake
dust
from all the cars is so fine the
particulates that they go through the
avioli in your lungs it's not even like
the carbon dioxide emissions it's the
brake dust
and it causes hypertension high stress
high blood pressure and that leads to a
lot of the stress that people feel a
couple
a couple of months after the start of
the pandemic with the lockdowns we're in
full swing
i was i went out to the middle of
nowhere in this rural area and i was at
a small little restaurant
and somebody noticed me and they were
like are you tim poole and i was like
yeah he's like oh wow and he's like nice
to meet you and he's like hey you mind
if i introduce you to some people work
i'm like hey of course
we started talking and i was like so how
are you guys holding up in the in the
pandemic with all the lockdowns and
stuff and they're like it hasn't
affected us at all
and i was like no like we were just
hanging out having a beer the other day
and like wondering what it must be like
in these cities where your lives are
destroyed and
he's like for us nothing changed at all
the only difference was
now they want you to wear a mask i guess
but for the most part nothing else has
changed changed
no i mean it was funny for a while um
every weekend different friends you know
from dc
would say hey do you mind if you know we
come out for the weekend and say hello
and then finally
after like two months andrew's like are
we running a bed and breakfast like
what is going on like every weekend we
have these house guests but i feel bad
for them you know they
they can't go outside it's in lockdown
mode there's
national guard patrolling the streets so
it was like yeah we'll give you a little
bit of refuge
i think i think if some of these city
people got to taste
the joy of responsibility in taking care
of your animals
and your family they would be addicted
to it instantly there's a genetical work
meaningful work rather than just empty
but budding pushing that they usually do
in the city
and the joy of seeing your dog run
without a leash
yeah is a is a pleasure like i took my
dogs you know to the city in the dog
park and would play with the other dogs
but to see my dog doesn't really know
what a leash is now and and i will not
put
him or her i have two dogs on one again
to see them just run and play and
and get dirty and my dogs are happy
everyone's happy
i'm happy you know there's just you know
people talk about
they need purpose in their lives purpose
doesn't need to be you becoming the king
and taking over and leading your
civilization to you know
conquest it could be you living for
someone other than yourself and when you
have animals to take care of
that also help sustain you chickens
laying eggs for instance or if you're
gonna if you're raising you know cattle
for meat or something
you have to take care of them because
they're ultimately gonna take care of
you that's your responsibility
you wake up in the morning and you've
got something some problem or some
threat or some storm or whatever
you have you have purpose if i don't do
this
bad things will happen i must take
action and that's lost for people in the
city because
it's it's almost like we beat the game
you know like you know humans have beat
the game
you live in the city what do these
people do let's be real
there are people who live in new york
who write articles
about you know brad pitt and and and you
know
they make 50 000 a year and complain
and they hate their lives and they're
like we need a union because i don't get
paid enough it's like
dude you realize that like there are
people who build
things and do backbreaking manual labor
making 15 bucks an hour
and you're getting double or triple what
they get paid to write garbage articles
these people have the cushiest
do-nothing jobs on the planet and that's
one of the biggest problems is making
this country fall apart
these media outlets have no idea have
the time to what to write about
because well you got to write about news
i'll give you a really good example of
what happens with video games
normally a video game comes out and
we'll call it ian's quest and you know
ian is a noble knight with a sword and
he's going to fight a dragon
and so they write an article ian's quest
is a new game that is xy and z it's fun
hear the controls whatever
then they write some some guides to that
okay great they wrote 10 articles
when the game came out the next day
there's no new game what do they do
what are they right about well what
happened was they figured it out
politics
can we complain about the game for some
reason oh someone noticed that one of
the dragons actually looks like
uh like he might be uh
misogynist yeah so the game is big
all of a sudden now they start writing
articles that were desperately trying to
find
anything to to be they're getting paid
tens of thousands of dollars to write
about this garbage yep
meanwhile you got some dude who's like
in montana
cattle ranching because he's trying to
make sure people in his community have
enough food and he has no idea what
you're talking about
now here are these people getting paid
tens of thousand dollars to write about
nonsense not only off of that but
they're also living off of the backs of
illegal immigrants that they're
benefiting
off of when they're paid low wage work
that they're serving them they're
they're cooking their food they're
giving in their food they're cleaning
after them
and and they're hypocritically talking
about the plight of immigrants calling
for more immigrants
as as of course they're benefiting from
it sorry go ahead no i was going to say
the dude in montana is healthier he's
he's probably hotter right i mean he
he's stronger
you know and it's like who do you know
for those of us on this persuasion and
for chicks
who would you rather get with the dude
in montana who's like like hurting his
cows or like the
buzzfeed seven things you didn't know
about geyser crystal water tea
guys to each their own
to each their own you know i guess
there's there's a lot of you know the
answer to that
that's correct yes you know it's funny
because i'll tell you this
the one thing that really angers the
left is pointing out the
the issues that are affecting cities
like they really
really get mad at me and so i've done
several segments talking about
women not finding relationships not
getting married and complaining about it
and so there's been several studies and
it's been left-wing publications
arriving
publications but the one thing that
really drives them insane and makes them
really want to come after me
is when i point out these articles where
it's like 30 year old woman says i can't
get a boyfriend or something
and so they try to you know it's just
they don't like that as
a conversation for some reason that
particular conversation
really really gets to them i don't
exactly know why and why it is if you
live in a city
and you're a you know uh woman past 30
who's working and you chose to do those
things i got no beef
i have more power to you man i'm all
about the freedom congratulations if
you're now upset you can't find a real
relationship
well i'm not ragging on you i mean i
guess life is tough you know
but there are these articles but that
really really strikes a chord
it really does it it just like a the one
thing that really gets them mad
i don't i don't maybe it's because it
really is an issue maybe because they
really don't like it i don't know
it is weird that when you look at the
city and there are millions of people
who are alone
um and lonely and and you interact with
thousands of them every week um but the
relationships are
are getting worse right the marriage
rates are plummeting uh the divorce
rates are skyrocketing so it so
how are all these people especially a
city like dc where i lived for
15 years 17 years how do all these
people who are between 24 and 34
and single not find love i think it's
the internet to be honest
probably you know it's changed the way
we used to communicate we used to
discover people we used to bump into
each other and then
find common bonds so i you know
people cyberstalk also which is a big
problem i meet this guy ian he's awesome
but before i have the first date
and i find old tweets and oh my god and
i don't believe this and oh my gosh you
like third eye blind uh i can't go out
with you
dude and it's part of why i won't didn't
research you i don't ask who's coming on
the show because i don't want to stop
before you get here well you know what
that is like the most mature thing i
have ever heard because other people be
like well let me find out every detail
and that's awesome you know and i hope
people do that in their dating life too
and be pleasantly surprised
ian do you like third eye blind i love
third eye blind oh no
london
uh semi-charmed life yeah it's about
coming down from from heroin i believe
wow crazy yeah so so here here's what i
want to point out going back to the
conversation about energy you know that
i have this article from la
from a couple almost two years ago now
it's from yahoo news actually it's from
the national review aoc's chief of staff
admits
the green new deal is not about climate
change
this is important context i know it's an
old story but considering the
conversation happening around texas
right now so for those of you that are
watching
if you get someone who says see aoc says
this is why we need a green new deal
okay all right that's the argument show
them this clip
this is what we have sciket chakrabarty
aoc's former chief of staff said
that addressing climate change was not
ocasio-cortez's top priority in
proposing the green new deal during a
meeting with washington governor jay
inslee quote
the interesting thing about the green
new deal is it wasn't originally a
climate thing at all
this is what chakra body said to
inslee's climate director sam ricketts
he said uh do you do you guys think of
it as a climate thing
because we really think of it as a how
do you change the entire economy thing
the green new deal proposed earlier this
year by ocasio-cortez and senator ed
markey
would transition the u.s economy
entirely away from fossil fuels within
10 years
while simultaneously providing a federal
jobs and health care guarantee
it would also according to its
proponents advanced social economic
racial regional and gender-based justice
and equality in cooperative and public
ownership
all told all told the proposal will cost
up to 93 trillion dollars in new
government spending over
10 years yadda yadda we get it okay so
put it simply let me ask you a question
a rhetorical question i'll i'll i'll
just reframe it actually if someone came
to me and said
do you think we should allocate taxpayer
funds
towards investing in new energy
technologies
in an effort to offset carbon emissions
i would say
yes if someone says so all of a sudden
you say yes they say boom you support
the green new deal
okay all right sounds good to me and
that's what they asked people
what they did not ask them was the
actual contents of the green new deal
do you support the largest transfer of
power to the government
economic uh power and economic control
to the government
in order to ensure racial uh you know uh
racial
and gender-based equity and guaranteed
housing and health care
that has nothing to do with the
environment that's going to dramatically
drop the amount of people who agree with
that one last point
chakrabarty said it was about changing
the economy
it's a new deal with green just jammed
in there
to use environmentalism as a
manipulation because when i read that
bill
i was looking for a legitimate
resolution that said
we're going to allocate x amount of
funds towards fusion we're going to
allocate x amount of funds towards
nuclear development which i knew they
would never do and we're going to
allocate x amount of funds towards
carbon capture and i'd be like let's
let's technology it's awesome man let's
fund technology they didn't
they said we're gonna guarantee health
care to people of color and i'm like
okay how about the land we're going to
guarantee income for those unwilling to
work
they must have read that and said wow
and they and they had to remove that
in panic and then try and deny it just
imagine
imagine the stupidity of someone who
says we are going to
get all fossil fuels in 10 years someone
who says that
just literally doesn't know how the
world works right it just does anytime
you say like
would you support this outcome that's
moronic like
would you support daniel winning the
race yeah sure well in that case let me
take any means necessary to make it
happen thank you that's basically the
new deal so they kill the three of them
and then i win well then
automatically you will win so so daniel
look look around the room
is there anything in this room that was
created without
fossil fuels it's not possible or if it
doesn't if it doesn't
contain a fossil fuel it was only
created
at a price point that you could afford
to put it in this room
because fossil fuel made it right the
wood that that was milled
you could afford to buy because it was
the trees were harvested
they were transported they were cut they
were brought to your home depot
all at a price point you could afford
and that's what's beautiful about the
free market system
it takes the most amount of goods and
lowers it to the lowest cost imaginable
and and just on a quick little note
right
to not to be political but the last four
years trump is an oil guy trump is an
oil guy he supports big oil
boy for a guy who supports big oil oil
prices were pretty damn
low right the oil companies want to make
profit off of
volume they were oil was at an even
before covid
oil prices were low because they were
producing more of it the industry the
free market wants to produce
more things at a lower price point
because more people can buy it so
let let's talk about price point and
that's good there's the story from way
back when
one man's nearly impossible quest to
make a toaster from
scratch now what does it mean from
scratch i'm not talking about and they
mention this in the article
a guy going to radio shack or home depot
whatever you buy components i need some
wire
i need some some metal no no he
literally wanted to make every single
part of it the springs
everything from the ground up guess what
he could not do it
he the one thing he couldn't do was
plastic i watched this video on it
he couldn't do plastic so he ended up
mining the plastic he went and found
some and melted it down
and all in all the toaster worked for i
think about 20 seconds before it broke
toasters cost what 10 bucks yeah for the
average person
working at mcdonald's takes about an
hour well after tax is about an hour and
a half two hours
and then you get a toaster this guy
could not make
the fact that we have this massive
industry
all of it 190 something percent fueled
by fossil fuels means that you can have
these things people cannot make on their
own
not only so the interesting thing about
it was plastics so
he couldn't he couldn't make it if he
wanted to he could do the medal he did
everything else but he couldn't actually
make the plaster which is funny because
you know fossil fuel-based for the most
part petrochemicals and things like that
think about you you brought this up
before the show ham sandwiches yeah
you want to tell the ham sandwich story
yeah it was it was similar to that and
and i have to find i don't remember
where i read it but it was a guy who
it was i forget where it was a guy who
wanted to make a ham sandwich same idea
though
every component he wanted to make he
wanted to grow the wheat
to make the bread he wanted to grow the
pig to make the ham
it took him years and it cost him i
think the price point was like like a
thousand dollars where he laughed and
said
i can go to the store and buy this ham
sandwich for four bucks or i could make
it on my own and it's a thousand dollars
and
years to make it happen again the beauty
of the free market i
i recently made uh with some friends
from scratch
some general sews chicken oh and
i was looking at the ingredients and i
was like the amount of things that had
to be pulled together to make this
would have been like one of the
manhattan project like 2000 years ago
there if you gave them that recipe
they'd be like what we have to get all
of these things to make this that's not
possible and and what amazes me about
the aoc's of the world
of of the haughtiness sometimes of our
elite is
the average person in america right now
the average person has the greatest
quality of life in the history of
mankind
you you find people who don't make an
awful lot of money who will say things
like oh you know i really like craft
beer and i like to get my craft beer
from this place
a generation ago we all drink our gr our
parents are growing
my parents your grandparents they drank
schlitz right because that's what was
available
and now with you dragon on schlitz i
know i i'm just saying that there were
four or five brands and that right
and now we find people who who because
we have
created such prosperity and that comes
from
an abundance of energy to go back to the
very first question why is there a food
shortage in texas
there's an energy shortage where is
there the most poverty in the world
where there's no energy
sub-saharan africa southeast asia where
is there the most pollution
and and and despair and the worst
quality of life
the same countries energy gives us
prosperity it gives us
the and and if americans are willing to
compromise their quality of life for the
environment
then i'm not going to stop them from
doing it but they need to know that is
what is on the line and to say we're
going to have a green new deal
but we're going to continue with all of
this is just a lie there's a balance
because i went to south america to
iquitos in northeast peru which is like
the last big city before you get into
the jungle
and honda basically got their tentacles
and aquitos and started
selling them these tuk-tuks these like
three-wheel cars and basically brand
them all honda and they're they use
like gas engines all of them so there's
like thousands tens and hundreds of
thousands of these
just pouring black smoke into the air it
smells
disgusting it's also considered the
dirtiest city on the planet
um that's because it's just all running
off gas with no carbon capture
taken into consideration so there's
about we need to learn how to
use it absolutely we need a balance
and and and i would argue that we have
allowed ourselves to have this binary
mentality we either love the earth or we
want to pollute it with fossil fuels
and i think they go hand in hand i look
at this country which is a very big
fossil fuel consumer
and our air our water quality we are not
a dirty country could we be cleaner of
course we could be cleaner right i don't
want to become this city
in peru i don't want to become that
but we're not there and so like we said
with the straw ban
we are chastising ourselves and
compromising our quality of life
for the sins committed by other
countries for the pollution created by
china for the
pollution created by indonesia and india
um
when are we going to stand up and say
you know what we don't throw i
i grew up in rockaway as i was saying
earlier
on the beach i've been to lots of
different beaches in this country i've
never seen
plastic strewn all over the place we
don't pollute our oceans in america
why are we culpable because greta phone
you pronounce it differently than i do
tells us well it's our fault there's
plastic in the ocean
yeah i think the h is silent is it i'm
pretty sure it's tuned i'm tired of
us being being having to compromise our
quality of life
for the sins committed by other
countries because there are countries
committing
great sins against the environment we're
going to find out that the carbon
dioxide in the air is valuable like a
natural resource to reuse and the
plastic in the ocean is insanely
valuable when you can melt it down or
break it down with fungus and bacteria
to turn it into sugar and reuse it it's
going to be worth
its weight in gold so if china wants to
throw it in the ocean so that we can
recapture it i'm totally into it just
give it
15 years carbon capture technology
converting the carbon in the air to
graphene like you were mentioning i
think is going to become lucrative
yeah and i think then we're going to
have an inverse problem where it's like
too much carbon is being taken like
and the plants will be suffering so
we're going to need to balance out that
it's true
we can't mine it at all out of the air
graphene has long been hailed as this
wonder material that's going to
revolutionize everything superconductor
materials what is it like you crisscross
it it becomes a superconductor
yeah so twist it something like that we
were talking about it
and there's a lot of amazing properties
that's like super strong
well you need carbon for that and you
you mentioned this earlier in the show
that they're going to capture it from
the air
to make graphene graphene is pure carbon
so you get the carbon dioxide out of the
air and
you put it on palladium apparently the
same metal that used for cold fusion the
palladium
it's incredible metal by the way um and
i didn't get through the article with
the process
earlier in 50 to 100 years when they're
like you know global cooling
catastrophe because too much carbon is
being extracted
by these graphene manufacturing plants
i'm sure they'll find something to be
you know there's articles going back to
the 70s obviously for the global cooling
this
my favorite article of all um which is
recirculated a lot is the uh
the un report of 1989 saying we had 10
years to fix climate change
and if not the maldives would be
underwater within 30 years
what about the 70s the global cooling
crisis yeah exactly you know
but i again i also think like i said
earlier i don't like
well i don't like i don't trust the
press and i also don't like government
and i
my whole life i've been told between
killer bees and swine flu and bird flu
and this pandemic everything's going to
kill me every five seconds we're always
told we're going to die this whole like
slow death thing is driving
i think it's a fear thing because we're
coming out of the last ice age right now
that's the research shows we're in a
what is it called um glaciation period
where everything's melting all the ice
caps are going to melt back to normal
we're out of the ice age and the real
fear is an asteroid impact
and a massive global flood not a slow
raise in the sea level it doesn't happen
like that it happens in jolts and jerks
so we got to prevent
and be prepared for that kind of thing
well we we need a we need to understand
a lot of things
it's it's not always you know so
strongly on one
side that there's going to be a solution
on you know there are some legitimate
issues that we do need to take care of
especially with the environment
especially with china especially with
other third world developing countries
especially things that we could
also do better and we should strive to
do better but we're not going to be
doing better when we're going to be
punishing people for living their lives
and doing it radically and listening to
people like alexandria ocasio-cortez
that literally said the world will end
in 12 years if climate change is not
addressed and
i i called my organization power the
future for a reason because
i do believe our future is better and
brighter and has fewer emissions et
cetera et cetera
but the geniuses who are thinking about
this and and and
the conversations we're having the
people who are going to laboratories and
factories and experimenting
are using conventional energy and if we
[ __ ] our conventional energy now
we are crippling our future those people
have to drive
they have to turn on lights they have to
run big machines so let's not
punish ourselves now for the hope of a
better tomorrow you know who's not
crippling their energy
china that's right look at the coal
plants they're building nor is russia
right if anything russia is laughing
itself silly so what you're saying is
that greta tunberg is working for the
russians to
to hurt america i am saying that there
is that this is newtonian
and there is always an an opposite
effect
and and by punishing american fossil
fuels
other people are going to prosper look
there they're only certain with geology
as such
that only certain countries have oil and
gas i wish they were all america in
canada because we're great but the other
ones are the saudis the omanis the
yemenis
the russians they're not the venezuelans
they're not the greatest regimes on
earth i heard a really
horrifying point i'm not the iranians i
don't remember who said it may have been
mike cernovich he said something like or
someone said
if you think the middle east is on is b
is destabilized now
wait until we discontinue use of fossil
fuels and then see what happens
what little is helping to stabilize that
area is
the desire for for profit and industry
and the access to this resource
once no one cares about that anymore
then fighting is going to be for just
just un or uncontrolled yeah
although like you said that pipeline is
all about moving moving fossil fuels so
we need it we may not have to fight over
that would be very different i'd imagine
yeah yeah they don't want to uh to pay
the high prices to russia anymore
so they want this pipeline built and
it's resulting in chaos
i've been thinking about if we were to
melt all the ice the countries that
would
massively profit or canada russia i
don't know how it does china is it
super far north up where china no no
russia is to the north yeah
more like russia it's russia russia will
be russia
make massive amounts of money when all
that well then all that ice is gone in
siberia and up there and they already
they already want to start drilling
and so there's now canada and greenland
is going to be
fascinating with no ice and we almost
bought it right our last president tried
to buy it for
i forget he wanted to put that casino in
there and you know have to get the price
tag it wasn't much you know we all could
have done a paper
a gofundme and who owns greenland is it
uh denmark
denmark oh my gosh yeah wow
yeah it's funny because denmark's like
pretty tiny like in europe
but it's like they have greenland it's
massive it's a whole lot of ice though
you know yeah i i will say this um the
ice on greenland is ice that is not
displacing water
so they say when that melts it will
change the salinity levels the flow
and potentially the water the ocean
levels themselves yeah
it melts on the inside and then it
breaks and floods and causes like a dead
zone of lack of salt water all this
fresh water well my question is like why
are these ultra elites buying beachfront
properties
no no but this is it's funny but like i
got someone sent me a video
where a guy said that he could debunk
climate change with one
simple fact and then he brought up that
some global elite
like i don't know who who it was bought
florida beachfront property
and he said how is that possible that
you have these people saying all this
because
all this is going to happen and they
just made a 30-year investment on
waterfront property
he said uh there's another video someone
sent me where a guy talks about how
if this was true no bank would issue a
loan to anyone buying or building on
beachfronts
but they don't care why is that but
just to finish this the argument from
the left is just simply because people
don't care yeah and that's a problem
or they don't believe because even as
you have now called them our lord and
savior bill gates
in his cnn interview on sunday said you
know we have 30 years
to fix this problem well aoc two years
ago said we had 10 years
at the at the presidential debates the
democrat primaries um
uh andrew yang said we have no time it's
already here
we should start moving people to higher
ground remember
the floridians were like oh boy pack
your bags kids i guess
you know we're moving somewhere right so
they know that this
timeline is a joke bill gates says 30
years aoc says
eight the legitimate scientists though
not the politicians
not the politicos or the people trying
to make money will tell you it's a lot
longer than that right so
there's a meteorologist who frequently
would debunk aoc
saying climate climate change and carbon
emissions they're serious problems
we need to solve for these problems ten
years that's not true yeah these people
are just
you know pushing trying to push you and
scare you and what's going to happen in
say it's 50 years are we going to be as
warm as we were
in the 1640s when england had very
prosperous vineyards right we're going
to be warmer
well we were warmer during the height of
the renaissance
were we all dying were we all under
water you know what i mean like we came
out of the black plague and
so yeah i don't know what the
consequences of of global warming are i
just hear it's catastrophe
all i know is that beneath the permafr
frost of greenland
are an awful lot of trees and all i know
is that when you go through the sands of
saudi arabia
there's an awful lot of seashells right
i mean that's ocean sand
from the last global flood so so we had
nothing to do with that
i i think it's very hard to think that
we have something to do with what's
happening now
well that being said let's jump over to
super chats if you have not already
smash that like button give a little tap
help out the show
don't forget to share this podcast if
you really do like it that's the best
thing you can do it's
seriously the only real way to grow a
show is if people are
advocating for it and uh hit that like
button subscribe notification bell and
go to timcast.com become a member to get
access to exclusive members only content
we got a full bonus episode with james
o'keefe it's a whole lot of fun but
let's read them super chats
all right let's see whoa it looks like
uh you know youtube changed the way they
did super chats and now i can't see the
time of when these were posted it's kind
of annoying
so it's a bummer so we've got let's see
can
uh control alt right oh what's that
about he says i'm super chatting while
plowing snow and yet
another pa snow storm tim tell me do you
shovel snow or do you make ian do it
we have a beautiful neighbor that has
taken the burden yes on the last
well i have to shovel snow out of my rv
roof today not fun i have to do that
every time and if you want to see luke
shoveling snow off his rv you can go to
my instagram does your neighbor have a
plow or something they're just doing it
he rides around on it he loves it he's a
truck it's a big truck yeah
but still but what a great meal yeah
yeah it costs money so
someone baked that guy a cake seriously
we were gonna buy like
four wheelers
says luke just bought a bunch of your
merchant merchandise post more pictures
of your puppy much love from louisiana
thank you so much the puppy's doing
really well she was having a really fun
day running around all the snow today
i'm going to post a video
uh on my instagram your ears if you want
to see that look where you're changing
one year
one year's performance the other one's
low ernie g says instead of learn to
code
learn to grow there should be classes to
teach people to survive
in worse conditions build grow and
survival yes definitely
i taught all right courses do you ever
look at like the education curriculum of
our grandparents when they learned how
to do things like
shop and shoot yes they've learned how
to do stuff
so i love i love that comment homeek was
awesome yeah
all right chris and shop those first
time cristos mourinho it's great or
something
crystals moreno says third super chat
the charm want a partner on
whistleblowerdeaf.org
had the idea for a while ago acquire the
perfect brand
dm'd ian on instagram cool there you go
what was it
uh partner on whistleblower.org i guess
they they the
dmd thanks for messaging me jennifer
rheem says texan here
we don't think about putting uh the food
from the fridge outside but did put beer
and wine outside to chill priorities
so did we there you go a smart move it's
one of the great things about living out
in the wilderness is you can put stuff
on your front porch and just leave it
there
or the back porch cody mcpherson says in
kansas our governor
laura issued an emergency because
natural gas companies raised the price
of gas
the price of gas over 100 times the
regular my small town i live in had a
bill of 10 million dollars for only six
days typical bill is 1.6 million for an
entire
year wow that's that's crazy
justin bookman says the reaction to
limbaugh reminds me when totalbiscuit
died
those games journalists were disgusting
by the way i'm starting a podcast called
the eye of buckeye soon
talking about ohio regional news thanks
for the inspiration hey right on man
i love that what up ohio i'm from
calgary falls
oh yeah shout out to northeast ohio grim
pickens says i'm a trucker
i deliver groceries to walmart stores
across m-o-k-s-i-a
and e-o-k we have spent more days parked
because of weather than moving the last
two weeks wow people don't understand
how fragile the supply chain is oh i
learned
because i got ups deliveries coming
we've got a fondue kit okay
yeah what happened with that i saw you
post that they were mistaken about the
tracking number no they told me that
they were like your package is out for
delivery
and then it's like severe weather delay
so i called can we just go pick it up
because the ups thing is only a few
miles away and they're like actually it
was never out for delivery
and it's not actually here and i was
like what whomp
but it's just
in switzerland i never felt more gay in
my life
this is the i've made it now now i'm
allowed back in new york
yeah i didn't vote for hillary but i'm
allowed i love it
you walk back in and they're like you
didn't vote for hillary did you i did
have grier
right this way sir
deplorable pirate captain gun beard says
the electrical grade
copper green energy requires cannot
economically be made from recycled
copper
green energy requires mining lots of
copper ore that uses lots of oil
chile actually reconverted their entire
economy to become a mining economy it's
like the third largest mining country in
the world
they have a lot of natural resources
yeah them in australia beautiful
countries you only find copper mines
around
volcanic area right that's part of it so
the ring of fire countries that's why
alaska has a huge copper mine that we
can't open
they've been fighting it for 17 years
but but copper has only found where
the same place is volcanic activity wow
all right we have a serious one here
from croup he says a pasco county
florida police officer and close friend
lost his life
yesterday in the line of duty he is
survived by his wife newborn child and
five-year-old daughters
his gofundme is named quote deputy
michael magley and family
pinellas county or pineas county how you
pronounce it and it's uh michael
m-a-g-l-i
and family if you guys want to check
that out group i'm sorry for your loss
and
my condolences to the family
acme products says ercot operates a
trading market for electricity
what happened in texas was a stock
market crash distributors aren't coming
online because electric is nine thousand
dollars per unit
when it's usually 25 this isn't only
weather this is enron stuff
wow oh so they spiked the price to make
money off this catastrophe
or it did the prices went crazy because
they
lost capacity and demand went through
the roof and then they couldn't operate
not entirely sure because 25 of the
electric grid is made from wind which
wasn't working
so they had to make up for it somewhere
right or they had to just continue to
cut
and so they cut off millions of people
and you either just keep cutting or
you add on capacity and if you're going
to add on capacity you have to buy it
from someone oh so they're they're
importing it to pay
yeah wow absolutely so this is a they
could be being spiked by foreign markets
no no it's spiked by its by just by by
the own demand and
of the yeah absolutely so we have uh
scrog gcw says tim you cannot run water
when it's cold if the power goes off
that runs your well pump this is why i
have a propane
power generator now that's true for for
a lot of people if you don't if you live
in an area without a water tower and
there's no natural water pressure
and you rely on an individual pump but i
think people in the cities where this is
happening
have water tower pressure don't you yeah
when when i grew up in queens
with a water i mean i don't think we
didn't have blackouts back then
right we had a better electric grid you
don't want to run the water full blast
you just have it a little bit more than
a drip yeah and then the water moves so
it can't freeze in the pipes
if the water stops then it freezes and
then you're in trouble
so we did this in chicago they all the
old buildings they would tell you in the
winter
keep the water on a drip or a little bit
more than a drip a little bit more it
can't just be a drip
publius the good says i built a green
building years ago with geothermal
cooling that's awesome
the bills in those apartments were less
than 50 bucks a month
this would be the best for texas
essentially you cool water by
circulating it through the bedrock to
cool it
that's awesome there's also this really
cool video i watched about
ant hills there are these kind of these
ant hills that are built like a tower
that funnels heat out of the colony and
and straight up and out
have you ever seen solar updraft towers
incredible technology they built a giant
circular tower at the base there's these
turbine generators
and then they build large circular tarps
around for like a mile around the tower
underneath not only does the sun hit the
tarp and then cause water to condense
underneath so in the desert for instance
it'll start to grow grass
but the hot air down there starts
rushing towards the center tower
turning the turbines going up the tower
it's incredible just
re they're super expensive to build did
you guys know that before the invention
of air conditioning we couldn't build
buildings above like eight floors
because the heat in the building would
rise to the point where the top
floors would just be too hot for humans
to want to be in and open the windows
and try and get air to circulate
they then invented air conditioners all
of a sudden now they could keep the
building cold
i watched this documentary it was
fascinating they said the technology to
build
bigger than eight stories has existed
since ancient times but we it was it
wasn't a part of our
our engineering our culture so now
modern buildings are built
built in such a way that heat is
funneled out of the building not
into the floors and colder air is is
brought in
so we actually have much more efficient
architecture where we don't need to
waste so much energy on air conditioning
it's crazy ac it's a fascinating
technology but takes a lot of juice
daniel bundrick says all they would have
to do to fix the supply problem in texas
is can the stupid anti-price gouging
laws there would be a backlog in the
highways of
their uh if there were no limit to what
you could make
the black metal says texan here people
need to adapt to all situations and help
others not depend on government ever
because when government fails more chaos
and sort ensues
prepare before help others after amen
yep good point
caleb davis says geothermal isn't worth
or effective in electricity generation
the largest plant in the world only
makes 1.5 megawatts for the land
large land area it uses well i don't
know i don't know too much about it i
can tell you this
i went to iceland once and i was talking
too much people there explaining to me
how iceland went from being this really
awful place to live
where people were always covered in
grime from like coal mining or whatever
they were mining just like really crappy
industrial labor for very little return
and then geothermal came and they set up
these geothermal plants and now they
have an abundance of energy
i think they even export some of it so
now you've got
people living really really well and
iceland is a really comfortable and
beautiful place
karasu matcha says hydroelectric thorium
and geothermal are the trinity of clean
reliable energy
fusion would be the king but i feel
geothermal doesn't get enough attention
oh contradictory so funny how how
drastic information can be
from person to person from one super
chat says it's useless to the next
person that says it's the holy grail of
energy
and they may both be right in different
circumstances
kevin says natural gas lines generally
freeze because of the presence of liquid
or
vapor water in the lines this is caused
by a pressure drop
in the gas lines which in turn drops the
temperature of the line interesting
thank you answered answered our question
yeah oh yeah
okay hydro hydro says luke go learn
something from thomas
sowell you don't even understand
economics but hate the rich
i don't hate the rich i like thomas so
well he's awesome i follow him and i i
retweet a lot of his memes and
not all problems are because of rich
people it's a small club of rich people
that really do create a lot of bad
problems but uh yeah if you're doing
well for yourself and you're an
entrepreneur
more to you and we need more of that all
right we got some hate you ready oh boy
michael cook says calling yourself an
expert with only five years in the field
is evident of a lack of self-awareness
i'm a 22 year old uni dropout and i am
more of an expert than this guy
similar blackout happened in south
australia 2016.
yeah and you know what they did as a
result they got rid of malcolm turnbull
who was the prime minister
because the people of melbourne said i
remember i'm engaged to an aussie
the people of of of victoria and
melbourne said
this isn't the third world why why we
have blackouts
because the freerus prime minister said
we're gonna start going green
so that was the consequence maybe that
maybe texas will make the same decision
what did you do
you so you spent last five years working
in energy
no working in energy advocacy and i had
to become an expert to do this job well
what did you do before that leading up
to it um i've always been advocate for
different issues you know i've always
been i've like i said i lived in dc for
a long long time
never ran for office or anything um but
i've always wanted to
fight for the underdog all right we got
it so i've done it from multiple i've
did it for i did it for free speech i
did it for religious liberties
um i've done it for lots of different
causes but this one i started on my own
because there was a need for it we have
this uh we have a comment super chat
from tyler cheney says look into liquid
fuel thorium reactors
the us built a prototype in the 50s with
none of the waste meltdown or security
issues
as conventional reactors it worked
perfectly and they never built another
also check out fl was it flibe energy
have you heard of that flea bay flyby
f-l-i-b-e
no idea interesting i'm afraid to google
things that i don't recognize
right right it could be a trick now
we're getting all these lefties being
like tim pool
actually said it that's a flyby jade
yeah right
j max says freedom is paramount if you
want to live in a pod live in a pond i
personally love
fried crickets with peanut oil and
smoked paprika but i'll be damned if
i'll make my standard v
standard crickets are super tasty though
i'm saying no i agree that's exactly it
when people are like i will not live in
the pot i will not eat bugs i'm like
imagine you had a pod in the middle of
the woods
and i don't mean a pot is like a tiny
little box where you're jammed i mean
like
a nice little relaxing a van even you
know you got enough space to lay back
you got your little tv you're playing
your video games you can see the stars
and you got some chocolate covered
crickets i i think people
i think people would not have the
opinions on eating bugs
if they just grew up eating them and a
lot of people in the world do and don't
care
yeah you know i mean one of the cool
things about america is there are still
parts of the country where people eat
squirrel and possum and other things and
and don't think twice about it and
yeah you know a pigeon so you know what
you know what i always confused me is
fear factor
you guys are watching for your face i
love that show the old ones were gross
yeah but like they'd be like
they would do the eating something
challenged and they'd be like we're
gonna make you
eat horse sperm food food food that's a
dude i love that show
but this is the point they would tell
people the fear challenge was they were
going to make you eat some animal part
and i'm like but that's just
food exactly i've had a bunch of weird
yeah there was a
uh like cow tongue every cow tongue
pretty common i like tongue
now fear factor did get cancelled
because i think it was bull emissions
oh yeah where they were and some dude
chugged it he was like i'm winning and
he just checked he knew that was when
the show went too far
he was like yeah yeah dude i love that
show that was my introduction to joe
rogan um and i loved it so much because
you'd see people in fear
like literally in panic and he would
inspire them
and like help them overcome their fears
and it was like he was just some dude
like some jabroni from the bronx or
wherever he's i don't know where
he's from boston but he was so like
loving to these people in their weakest
moments that i i had so much respect for
that guy
i liked it when it was fear like you
have to put your hand in here i'm not
telling you what it is
when it was just gross out factor yeah
right right but when it was genuinely
like
i'm not going to tell you what i'm going
to put on you but we are going to put an
animal or like jump from a moving
vehicle to another moving vehicle
you can do it and he's like you can and
he was really give them like
inspiration man that was it's just like
they're gonna make you eat something
you're not gonna get hurt you know i
mean they're gonna put your hand in
something an animal on you you're not
gonna get hurt
all right we got this big one from
geraldo aleveres thanks for the super
chat
from texas came to the ranch because it
had it had power
city texans seem not to be prepared
self-reliant
work in ong with many between us and
wind they prefer wind because it's
heavily subsidized
there was a power dispatch issue wind
isn't scalable
we're not against wind but realize its
issues and resources
nuclear is the future you're here sir
thank you for the super chat absolutely
batteries man because sometimes it's
super windy and you would charge the
hell out of those batteries
and then because the wind doesn't always
blow yeah and the sun doesn't always
shine
and as he said no one's opposed to it
but you have to realize
it has limitations so let's be adults
and acknowledge the limitations
this is an interesting one danny
stevenson says quote a theory of natural
philosophy written in 1763 by joseph
boscovich was nikola tesla's favorite
book
it explains the aether in detail we need
to go back to aether technology i.e
tesla tower
watch adapt 2030 latest vid well i don't
know anything about that but i love
those kind of conversations about like
lost technologies or like new mysterious
you know forms of energy and stuff and
tesla is always a fun subject yeah
having the earth's magnetic field would
be interesting the energy generated by
the core spinning
the core of the earth
god emperor says tim they they do not
want people becoming self-sufficient
they want us in the cities
and being controlled they are just not
very good at anything
that's actually a really good point yeah
pretty much yeah
i think that's true don't you stuck
lori from arizona says truck drivers far
outnumber the members of congress
we could do far more damage to this
country in a much shorter time than any
person in congress
i wish all two million would agree to
stop until the bs in this country ends i
i am one myself
maga yeah people don't realize the power
they have you could literally be like i
will not buy
from this store anymore and that's it
yeah there's the change
until someone's got driving trucks
replace them which is happening very
soon
yep ethan wiley says the wind industry
doesn't employ people
that thump you with the green deal crap
we are majority diesel truck
money and usa loving americans we don't
see many soyboys out here can't handle
70-hour weeks
would be my guess i mean i absolutely
assume that the people who are building
infrastructure
i don't care if it's wind or otherwise
not gonna be
frail little soyboy that's the funny
thing about these people
they're not the ones doing the work but
they claim to be the proletariat yeah
it's like
these these college educated kids coming
out saying that they're the working
class like dude you're not you're
writing about brad pitt's junk for
buzzfeed you know i mean i did a little
study on flibe
that technology they called it earlier
it's lithium fluoride uh beryllium
fluoride lithium beryllium flibe and
it's
it's uh served in making molten salt
reactors it really looks like
thorium might end up becoming the holy
like the
it's been people been talking about for
like 15 years and i think it's just
going over people's heads
so no one's really seized this element
but
it sounds incredible if you can melt
salt and store heat with it andre lopez
says this is why i want to buy some land
buy a tiny home trailer for 65k and just
live happily with my gf
i just watched a video of some dude who
made a concrete
dome and it was like five grand for this
dome it's not particularly big but it's
big enough
and it was amazing it took them like
only a cup i think only
took them like a day it was it uses
inflatable yep and then you you spr you
put uh
mesh over it and then you spray it with
concrete then you put wiring concrete
wiring concrete boom
then you gotta like you know put in the
insulation and make it look pretty and
that guy is happier in his home
than any of these like defeat liberals
in the city
are in there yeah but you know van life
has becoming
has become extremely popular a lot of
young people are like dude living in a
van by the beach
is way more fun than living in a
concrete cubicle in new york city that
you know smells like sour milk
this channel was originally called the
van chan
day one what channel this tim cast irl
the first episode was the van but this
wasn't the
channel yeah you called it well you
mentioned you were like i think i built
the van chan dude
no no no no no this was tim cass ireland
was a was it was supposed to be general
general
the first video was you like pimping out
your van like showing everyone your van
but the channel wasn't about the van
oh i thought this was the van no i just
we i built a van and i was like
i'm gonna do a van video and show you
everything and it got like a hundred and
some thousand views overnight like
everybody was like
but then i was like you know lock down
what are we gonna do
it's really hard to do a vlog so it
became more of a show here we are almost
a million subscribers
we are really close to a million so if
you haven't subscribed make sure you
subscribe and tell your friends
subscribe because we are seriously close
to breaking a million
and then i'm just gonna i'm gonna love
it when google is forced to give me uh
another gold medal or whatever award
melissa k says i love hearing you talk
about self-sufficiency and rural living
should check out rooted new docu-series
from justin rhodes
amazing homesteading resource
interesting
matthew maddox says pea fowl is old
world turkey
use them for meat so you mentioned the
peacocks
yeah i mean i'm i guess one they can no
longer lay
i guess you know you could stew it yeah
i don't know i'd be tough and gamey but
right now we're using them for the eggs
so i don't want to kill my
my my hands when i when i lived in miami
there was a uh
one farm i guess that had peacocks and
they just had no they didn't care they
like were walking around on the roads
doing whatever and it was like you just
slow down wait for them to pass and
sometimes they'd scream at you and run
at you and i'm like
great don't you got to close your
friends or something they didn't care
the people who live there they're
they're chickens walking all over the
place just doing whatever they want
that's the crazy thing to me i'm like
aren't they going to get killed like
roosters protect them i'm like really
like coyote won't fight the rooster like
no they don't want to get no fight
roosters are there the chickens are good
i'm like oh okay i'm crazy
i guess i don't know or i suppose you
still need something to deal with you
know wild animals
but uh i guess people used to get dogs
for watching my dogs
yeah we'll keep out the wild animals
yeah the other day there was a fox
on the other side of the fence that was
teasing it and so for fun i threw the
dog on the other side of the fence
and i would never kill the fox because
foxes are beautiful and it really you
know they are
that's where again living in the country
you learn the expression clever like a
fox is a real thing
they are smart little animals they are
crafty and they are and they like to
tease dogs when they know a dog
is behind behind a fence and uh it was
pretty funny to see that fox
turned 1899 or um feline
or are they one of the other do they
have their own boxes yeah they're
probably
canine they're not cats they're probably
i mean yeah if they're either
are they either or they just hold it
from a breed but they're not i don't
think they're feline
mr ruckus says five bucks to hear lydia
say hi dave ruckus please
hi dave ruckus thank you for your five
dollars we really appreciate it
you ju1 says hello tim this is your
follower from south korea
i wonder when did you visit korea before
south korea is now politically deeply
divided and you should look into how
china penetrates into korea now sad face
yeah it was so awesome we went to the
house we were at a hostel yeah
that's what i preferred to say yeah i
was like i'm like we got to go to the
hostel
and it's it's a great way to meet people
and explore and find like-minded
individuals who have this
kind of energy for ex for adventure
remember we got that crazy spicy thing
at that
restaurant or whatever yeah there's a
lot of that
we went there when we sat down in in in
a restaurant in south korea
everything's you know i'm like what i'm
like just give me anything
and yeah i was like whatever surprised
me and i really that was a good decision
to make
we went to one place that i can't
remember exactly what it was
but we got we were like yeah spicy and
we regret it it was like the spiciest
thing i started making
farm animal noises you remember that i
was like give me give me moo
i was like i don't mean to be rude but
like there's a language barrier which is
hey i have no language barrier i have uh
sign language and
noises that uh that make sure i could
communicate with everyone that's a big
skill i learned
foxes are canines also called canids as
well as wolves and jackals
dog family and luke you should get one
brian brian omar says pigeon soup is
really good
in puerto rico we say it can resuscitate
the dead oh
boy what was the was it what was the
pigeon that uh that we drove to
extinction do you know what i'm talking
about
uh passenger passenger pigeons yeah
because people there were so many of
them i think so that people in america
would just like throw it and
catch them all and then eat them and
then eventually they're all gone oh yeah
good job
everyone wipe them out all right we'll
just do a couple more here
bell bells nickel says tim for wells and
circulate water for geothermal or a pit
with tubing will lower your heating and
cooling by half
yeah that's amazing geothermal
technology for home heating and cooling
that's cool stuff
you run basically you have like an outer
layer of your house with glass walls and
then so you run the water underneath the
air
cools but then the sunlight heats it so
it rises and then pushes the air
have you got a circular pattern have you
guys seen the new solar capture
technology
where it's this chemical that's a closed
system that can catch and release solar
energy
so it's a liquid that when sunlight hits
it it
like essentially absorbs some of those
photons like
whatever however it works i'm not
entirely sure and like the liquid
changes color
and then they can use an electrical
current to release that energy like a
light current or whatever will
release a ton of that energy out and in
the form of heat
and so there's a lot of theories about
the applications you could have
these like uh you could have like tubes
on the top of your house full of the
fluid
absorbing solar energy but then they
circulate into the house
where it releases the heat in the
basement raising the heat
up so basically takes the heat from
outside the on the roof and puts it
underneath and then raises
we're transferring from an electronic
organization to a photonic one and it
sounds like you're
involving chromatics to store heat
austin s says someone tell ian that
methane is one carbon not four no no one
carbon four hydrogens
dom ch4 ch4 that's what i meant to
say i just said it quickly earlier thank
you all right we'll just do this one
last one any names in this audience
ever talk about all the lithium in
bolivia and what superpowers are uh
are going to fight for it wow there's
lithium and bolivia oh i don't know
i i did not know but i mean i'm sure
look at china is controlling the cobalt
mines of of the congo
right if there's lithium in bolivia then
there's a chinese
camp nearby getting ready to conquer it
that's what people need to be paying
attention to man you know
there's so much dumb stuff happening in
this country and what really worries me
is joe biden placating defending china
and then you see the distractions we get
from these commissions on the capital
riot and impeachment
meanwhile china what are they doing
they're romping around the planet oil
exploration in these other countries
has me worried man with that being said
uh dan thanks for hanging out
it was awesome thank you for those that
are listening make sure you smash the
like button subscribe hit the
notification bell and seriously share
this podcast if you really do like it
tell your friends
post a link if you're listening on any
podcast platform leave us a good review
you can follow me on parlor minds and
any any other platform that's not the
big ones i'm trying to not
encourage that uh at tim cast my other
youtube channels are youtube.comtimcast
and youtube.comcastnews i guess except
for youtube obviously
and we do the show monday through friday
live at 8 pm so make sure you come back
tomorrow we're gonna be talking about
guns and it's going to be a whole lot of
fun oh yeah and uh yeah but
dan do you want to shout out any social
media or any website or anything uh yeah
you can follow
powerthefuture.com you can follow me on
on twitter and i
was an early adopter for parlor so i am
at daniel which i'm kind of
kind of proud of very nice so i was
tweeting during the show
my live tweets are available on luke we
are changed a lot of crazy stuff's
happening i tried to interject it but i
didn't find any way to talk about how
pewdiepie
got his video taken down by youtube
deleted uh bill gates just called for
cryptocurrencies to be
uh getting rid of so lots of crazy news
happening right now and
i report on it especially about
individuals like bill gates that i did
a very interesting video about today on
my independent media channel called
we are change make sure to subscribe and
click the notification button on that
to see all the wacky weird and
interesting stuff that i do on that
channel thanks for having me what's up
everybody thanks for coming in across on
um pickup at timcast.com i'm a gorilla
t-shirt if you want to support the cause
maybe get a my pillow while you're at
our pillow it's called our pillow
i feel bad but if you want to get a my
pillow go for that too we're all on the
same team
um and hey follow me and crossland.net
you can get some of my new merch
including this free the code
for the code mug i really said my pillow
i feel like such a scumbag
our pillow and then me sour patch lids
i'm at sourpatch lids on twitter
and mines and i am at real sour patch
lids on instagram and
gab make sure you go to timcast.com and
become a member to get access to a ton
of exclusive content we have a whole
bunch of posts unfortunately tonight
we're not gonna have any more bonus
content but we do have a full hour with
james o'keefe check it out
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all tomorrow
you